e
it is N9 o'clock and we will get started
um and uh we're here to welcome the
department of administrative services
and um commissioner Arling house um I
want to say first that um I I handed you
all this U paper that compar 2019 to
2025 and this was commissioner Arling
House's suggestion and I think it's
because it madees his Department look
like the best one we have because from
2019 to
2025 their general fund allocation is
down
4% um and that compares with uh like HHS
okay so anyways uh thank you for coming
and let's get
started um as advertised I'm Charlie
Arling housee I'm the commissioner of
administrative services and joining me
are Deputy Commissioner Cassie Keane and
assistant commissioner Sherry Rockburn
um Cassie's a lawyer Sherry's an
accountant and I have no discernable
Talent just why I'm in the
middle um we're going to uh talk to you
about who we are and where we spend
money and and this is not a preview of
what the governor might do because we um
if we knew we couldn't tell
you um so um if you look at the second
or the slide numbered page one I want to
just mention what what we are and what
we aren't um we have more
administratively attached boards than
anybody in state government and and to
remind people what those are because
they're weird there are a bunch of tiny
independent
agencies that are independent in every
way I'm not the boss of them I don't get
to tell them what to do um their budget
is submitted to you Untouched by us and
we don't say anything but because
they're so little one employee three
employees five
employees um periodically the
legislature will
say I want you to do the HR and um the
some of the finance back office work for
them so we do that and in fact um I'll
you'll see later we have a
position that was given to us because of
this right right now we have five in
2019 there was one so our our spend
looks like it went up more than it did
in some reports or didn't go down as
much as it
did um because of that but now there are
five there's a six that's being added
the Personnel appeals board and uh
Deferred Comp commission may turn out to
be a seventh depending on um what the
where that ends up going in the
government structure so anyway that's
that's who we are I'm going to talk to
you about Das not about the attach
boards so on page
two
um the chairman stole my
thunder and this is I we are the lowest
spending agency in state government we
went down 7% where everybody else went
up something like
33% and I'm very proud of that we're
going to talk to you about how that
happened and the way in which it
happened um a big piece of that is the
retiree Health story which is is
something we're very proud of but I I
would just say this that if even if you
I'm going to end with the slide too just
because I like how it looks and I'm
going to post it on my wall um this
afternoon and I'm going to send a copy
to the governor and everyone else you
can think of um so go if you go to page
three I I want to I'm going to explain
to you how I'm going to talk about our
department how we're going to talk about
our department our general fund spend
and and this is the 25 adjusted
authorized spend so it's not as past in
the budget it's the number that you'll
see in the agency phase budget documents
and and as a line item in in the
governor's document when that's
produced um and it has all the house
bill two spending pumped into it because
the the the legisl and the governor
spent a lot of money in House Bill too
including a pay raise but this gives you
an idea what we're actually spending and
if you look our department is half
retire health and half everything else
in a really odd way this year it's
almost exactly half it's 31 767 and
31757 um so we're going to talk first
about
we're going to talk to you about one of
the
greatest stories in state government
right
now um know it's a phenomenal success
story in terms of uh strategy and
spending and it won't always look like
this but we're going to take as much
credit as we can because so many people
did so many good things on it and to
tell you about it I'm going to let
Cassie talk good morning everyone um
Cassie Keen I'm Deputy Commissioner but
um more importantly I'm the former
director of the division of risk and
benefits and um when I was director I
was in charge of administering retire
health benefits we have um over
12,500 retirees and spouses on our
retiree health plan some of them are
what we call non-medicare retirees and
there are about 1580 of those and we
also have Medicare retirees um
10,906 of those um some of you have been
here for years and we've been talking
about retiree Health you may remember if
they're Medicare retirees we bring in
federal funds to to help mitigate the
cost of those Medicare
retirees um and so Medicare retirees are
much non-medicare retirees are much more
expensive to cover than um Medicare
retirees for example the premium for our
non-medicare is
$478 per month um that is because we're
self-insured and we pay for the claims
of those
individuals um part of the story I'll
tell you about U Medicare retirees as we
go through the the chart is we we
implemented strategies to ensure all are
part of the Medicare population and we
were able to leverage federal dollars
and that's a big um component of the
savings that you see here but I was
thinking last night as I was reflecting
on um my favorite history which is
retire health and um I was remembering
when I came back to State service in
2013 and joined Das that one of the
first things I had to do um was go to
fiscal committee and report on retiree
health and at the time um what came out
of um the budget process was a a a
budget that everyone knew was going to
squeak if if we were lucky right and so
we did an analysis of of the funding and
we were able to say to the legislature
at that time we're good if I if I if I
take into account and and we have grown
as we've become as we were self-insured
and we've gotten better and better at
managing our health benefit plan that if
we if we did our analysis in depth and
and um and considered the cost of
non-medicare and Medicare back in 2013
we we slid by and what I what I thought
about that was boy I didn't know what I
didn't know what was coming at us right
so fast forward to 2016
and um it retire Health became a huge
problem for the State of New Hampshire
for das and quite frankly for the
finance committees okay so what happened
was we were in um coming out of the
governor's budget we were underfunded
for our projected need and then what
happens in healthcare happened Pharmacy
cost took off there was a 16% inflation
rate back then and so all of a sudden we
found ourselves in a $10 million
um projected deficit situation and that
began I think a period of partnership
rep rler may recall where we worked very
closely with the F the finance committee
to um to manage retire health and how we
spend the money so that we could meet
our statutory obligation which is to
administer re retiree health benefits
within the funds appropriated by the
legislature so in 2016 we worked with
the fiscal committee there are two ways
you can change retire Health um it it is
it is legislative action is required so
the legis full legislature can do it or
the fiscal committee can do it fiscal
committee doesn't really want that
responsibility just so you guys know
because it's 10 people and they they
really felt like shouldn't 400 people be
voting on this right so in any event we
were trying to solve a short-term
problem at that time and what um the
fiscal committee decided Ed was to
increase premium contributions the
amount that the retirees contribute to
the cost of um their care and at that
time the only retiree group that had a
premium contribution was the
non-medicare group and they had over the
years paid a lump sum of 65 bucks it
went up to 12 a half% it went up to
175% by fiscal Committee Action they
also changed some co-pays those are two
examples of the levers that we have that
we can adjust to meet Our obligation to
fund retire Health within the um funds
appropriated by the legislature so so in
2016 after we completed the fiscal
process we knew we knew retire Health
was going to be a forever problem if you
will right and that we had to manage it
some of you may remember this it's um
our long-term study on options to adjust
the retiree health benefit plan and it
goes through uh a myriad of options
the pros of them the cons of them Etc
and um one of those options in here was
considering a Medicare Advantage plan um
again this is 2017 and at the time the
network for Medicare in New Hampshire
was not robust enough to meet Medicare
um standards and so coming in um out out
of 2017 we were watching this but it
wasn't an option then at some point in
2018 our vendor and Anthem said to us
hey we've got the network would you like
us to work with you on Medicare
Advantage and we said yes and so
beginning in
2019 where you see the first result in
savings what we did was we fully insured
Medicare retirees for their medical
services only right not their Pharmacy
we kept the pharmacy self-insured um
through our vendor Express Scripts and
so for um 19 and 20 and 21 we worked
with anthem on Medicare Advantage and we
were in a contract we we um amended that
contract Etc and then when you look at
2022 and you see our that we really
really did a great job of savings right
through a procurement process we um went
out to bid and we um contracted with
Etna and we actually achieved a zero
premium and you might sit there and say
how could you do that right and it was
because it was because the vendor atna
was relying on the federal reimbursement
and they they were counting on that they
would meet their costs with the federal
money and that they wouldn't have to
charge us anything and um so that's
that's that's the other part of the
success story you have here right and so
um what I what I think I want to say and
and some of you have been here for years
have heard me say this we're really
worried that this Medicare Advantage is
our last rabbit to pull out of the Hat
you know um and so and so knowing that
we were facing sort of uh what what are
our future options oh they don't look
great we decided to do to experiment one
more time and when we went out to bid in
late um in in 23 for
24 um we we bid in the alternative we
bid for uh our Medicare Medicare
Advantage retirees and we asked the
biders to price out just insuring the
medical and then we asked them in the
alternative price out medical and
Pharmacy and we were successful in um in
in even beating the the rates that we
had in the past so when you look back at
your chart here and you see
2425 it reflects um that contract
arrangement 26 is unknown to us and and
we're um we're quite sort of on on pins
and needles watching what happens at the
federal level so a lot is happening at
the federal level right now that none of
us really have a crystal ball to figure
out but um even earlier in
2024 we were hearing um that the federal
notices about funding for Medicare
Advantage were going to tighten down
tighten up the the reimbursement levels
so we're watching 26 very carefully
again our concern is we're at of rabbits
right so
um so that's the story of our Medicare
safe our our um retiree health benefit
savings I'm I'm just going to see if I
um oh oh do you want me to talk about
pering contribution yeah okay one thing
I forgot to tell you folks
um if you may recall I mentioned earlier
that in
2017 the only retirees paying a premium
contribution were non-medicare retirees
and that really tied our hands in terms
of tools because the larger part of the
population was paying nothing and so um
we worked with governor cunu and his
budget officer and for the we introduced
and was passed by the legislature a
firsttime premium contribution for our
Medicare population now when you think
about Medicare it's important to
remember these are older people right
they're unfixed incomes Etc I think when
I first started um analyzing retiree
Health we had two people over the age of
100 we now have 21 okay so the
population is aging people are living
longer and and yeah except when we're
paying for retire Health right and so um
and so uh by the way passing that
premium contribution was difficult
politically and um those of you were who
were here may remember we worked very
hard in particular with representative
Ober and we grandfathered um the oldest
of the retirees who had the lowest
pensions and so retirees who were born
January 1 149 and earlier were
grandfathered and today pay nothing
toward the premium contribution there
are
4759 retirees who today do not pay a
premium contri bution because of their
age um and and as as that group um
diminishes the group paying increases
and now we have over 6,000 retirees who
are paying that 10% premium
contribution all right so uh let's have
some questions I I think I saw
representative Ms and then
representative rung thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so the
these expenditures these are um are
these expenditures for claims or are
these
um some kind of contribution to some
post-retirement liability no no um they
are they are to pay for retiree health
and so when we're self-insured we pay
the medical claims and the prescription
drug claims just give me the bill I pay
it right when we're fully insured the
carrier taking on the risk and we pay
the rate the monthly rate so when we
went to when we went to Medicare
Advantage for the first time and and
ensured that medical portion of the
benefit benefit that had a rate
Associated that we paid to Anthem the
carrier and we self-insured the
prescription drug claims so it includes
both self-insured claims and insurance
rate okay and problem and then so when
you you had mentioned that um when you
when we moved to Etna there was a zero
premium on the uh on the Medicare um so
I'm assuming therefore that a lot of
these dollars that are left are are uh
prescription drug claims and
non-medicare expenditures correct okay
okay and one one last
one
um uh what happened to the um the
retirees um co-pays and out of-pocket
um expenses or maximums when we went to
Medicare Advantage did that increase
significantly they all stayed the same
again we we have no authority to change
it except with action by the legis
rung thank you very much um I uh I'm new
to this committee so I apologize if you
know some of these questions seem pretty
basic but so we have a group of retirees
who are younger than the Medicare
eligibility age right younger than I
think it's 65 okay how many are there
compared to those that are medic
medically um Medicare eligible I'm sorry
180 nonm Medicare okay and um
10,906
Medicare okay um so the the the people
that are um Medicare eligible do they
still have to pay their part Fe premium
I'm assuming they do okay and
so why do we even offer retire why don't
they just go on Medicare and then
perhaps have their own personal choice
whether they want to get an advantage
plan or a Supplement Plan with separate
Part D so I I I think I I'm not exactly
sure when when retiree health started
but I think it may go back as far as the
70s do you know particularly I I think
so um for for a lot of large companies
and and governments the the you know
Medicare doesn't cover everything and so
a lot of people have a metag gap plan of
some kind and a lot of large companies
and governments offer it and so this was
always an employee benefit and like if
you talk to the union um it was sort of
bargained or or understood so we've just
had it as a as a benefit they could you
know people people could uh could buy
one themselves but they would kind of
rather have us buy it for them so and
Medicare doesn't pay for all costs so
part of what our plan does is wrap
around what Medicare pays and it you
most of our retirees pay very little for
the healthare compared to the average
American um one thing I want to mention
for you because I could I I know where
you're coming from I think um one of the
things that the legislature has
recognized from beginning back in
2009 when there were very liberal
eligibility requirements for retire
Health right that we needed to um sort
of uh contain who who who can be
eligible for retire health and so um
what are the what are the two elements
that make up eligibility one's age and
one's years of service we we call it
credible State service and what it means
is that not only are you a state
employee but that you are also
contributing to the to um the retirement
plan the pension plan right um and so
over the years it for example I'm
thinking of group two there used to be
no service requirement this is back in
the 2000s okay and what we would what
what we experienced was there would be
group two people who might have worked
in municipality their entire career they
would come to the state work here for a
year or two retire and then the state
was paying retire Health that was not
rewarding someone for for um dedicated
State service and so
today um group two eligibility is 52 and
a half and 20 years of State service I
think and um no 25 I believe and group
one eligibility is 6
and 20
years so when I think of this picture of
managing
retiree I have to leave a few minutes
I'm sorry that's okay can so those that
are retirement um Medicare eligible and
they're on the Medicare Advantage plan
there is significant out of-pocket costs
on those um you know compared let's say
Medicare with a supplement does the
state cover those out- of pocket costs
not not entirely there are and and I'm
I'm not up on those details like off the
top of my head but we do have co-pays
for um like physician visits and
impatient hospital we have co-pays for
for prescription drugs we have maximum
out of pockets right so they they still
do pay and and when going back to your
initial question and I forgot to answer
one thing you asked me so Medicare
retirees do pay A Part B premium it's
monthly and it's it's pretty significant
um it is um let's see in 24 it was
17420 a month and in 25 it's 185 a month
right so if again thinking about why did
we grandfather people because they're
already paying so much for that Medicare
Part be by the way go back to the the
2000s one of the things the legislature
did when it made changes to try and
contain costs was to we used to pay for
that Medicare Part B premium and so now
the retirees pay for it but you asked me
a question about that was essentially um
why don't we just give them a payment
and let them go purchase some kind of
Health Care coverage for themselves it
actually is one of the options that we
discussed in here and we would use
something called a healthcare exchange
if that ever came to pass um and
essentially what you do is contract with
a a a company that works with retirees
to counsel them on options for various
health care plans right and what what
might be what is your employer paying
toward the cost of retire health and
then you consider what do you want to
buy do you want to buy something more
expensive you're going to have to reach
into your own pocket you want to buy a
very lean plan and take the risk okay
you can do that you can pocket the money
but you're on you're on you're you're at
risk so okay all right thank you um
would you mind leaving your card can I'd
like to follow up sure okay thank you
very much representative wer thank you
Mr chair
congratulations commissioner that's that
was a big change and fiscal is always
willing to help when you come up with
new ideas thank you the only thing I
want to comment on I have a good friend
that's a retired uh state employee with
diabetes and he keeps complaining to me
every time I see him about Caroline oh
he said what a lousy contractor they are
I hope you're going to get rid of them
what's what's the um changes there if so
so
um I'm going to start by saying um we go
out to bid we choose the lowest bidder
as long as they meet technical
requirements um if anyone in this room
thinks that um carry that contractors
let alone insurance carriers do what
they they should do without intervention
by us you're wrong okay so we have a
history I think in Risk benefits of
really working closely with our vendors
to make sure they deliver the services
to our members whether they're active
employees and families or retirees so
this year when we went out to bid Anthem
won the contract back from uh Etna and
um they uh they snookered us a little
all right they did not disclose to us
that they were implementing their own
Pharmacy Benefit Management subsidiary
PBM okay and um we moved our retires
to um car to Anthem and Caroline was the
subsidiary right and um and they stink
and and they were not ready yes they
stunk they couldn't have stunk more
quite frankly it it became chaos it was
very problematic for our retirees for
the governor for the legislature for the
executive Council for the legislature
there was a ton of abrasion right and so
we worked we worked very very closely
with Anthem um to fix the issues we
assessed performance guarantees and
collected over $2 million in performance
guarantees because of their um inability
to perform we stopped payment for a
period of six months until they be until
they fixed it right so I think our
monthly premium was 1.8 million we did
not pay them okay um we then uh worked
with a third-party auditor to audit the
carolon pharmacy
processes and um to make sure first of
first and foremost that people get their
medicine right um but did they get the
right customer service and I I kind of
feel like if you went down okay are they
filling prescriptions are they are they
answering the phone are they giving
accurate information when you answer the
phone it would be
like right and we had to get them to
check check check right so we worked
with them very intensely over six months
and I'm very proud to say that often we
say we teach these companies how to do
business okay and so um and so that is
what we did with Caroline and we've come
out the other end it's not perfect it
never is customer service quality
customer service is a huge challenge out
there okay so so we still have to
intervene but it's so much better thank
you you you could have gone to Express
Scripts instead or stayed with Express
SCP well remember we fully insured the
prescription drugs so we could get the
savings and this is the risk what
happens when you switch
vendors it's risky you know you're
always waiting and wondering how' it go
how' it go right and um and
unfortunately it couldn't have gone
worse all right represent a evil yeah I
just have a really easy quick question I
think how often do you go out to bid
annually or for the banum no we tend to
go out to bid um usually for three-year
period and and often we include
Provisions to extend up for two
additional years um so uh it it's
sufficient to test the market by the way
we we work with our medical consultant
and we know that that's a good interval
so the contract that we're in right now
started will end when um let's see
uh calendar end of calendar 26 yes yes
thank you so the the details of the plan
are in law is that correct I mean in the
sense that the 20 years and the copay
and some of these other things or so so
some of the some of the co you're not
going to find the copays the max out of
pockets and all that stuff in the law
but we wouldn't change it without coming
to the legislature we have no authority
to do it um and were we to do that I
think we'd have to work in Partnership
to talk about just how much detail did
you want in the law and figure that out
so there's no requirement that it be any
particular level I mean in terms of
contractual requirements with the
employees no the only legal requirement
is that the retire health benefits are
administered within the funds
appropriated by the legislature I see
but historically the state has paid for
reti health sure but the the point is
the legislature could say we want to put
100 million into this or 90 or 80 and
you could work out absolutely the
details to make yes ends meet yeah yes
okay and and and retire I just do want
to say the retirees are are experienced
state employees and they know how to um
be advocates for themselves of course
yes representative mths thank you thank
you just as a followup to that so there
so there is nothing in any of the
contracts that the state has with its
employees that governs retire health no
no requirement that has to be offered so
so retire health is I let me ask answer
your question this way it is not
law if it if it comes down to it there
are a lot of different levers you could
push and we could help um show you the
menu so you knew what you might be
pushing what is this book you're waving
around this is the long-term study from
2016 from early 2017 when we had a
crisis and it's basically the actuar
saying you could do this or you could do
that this is this is why it's a good
idea this is why it's a bad idea gotta
sure right thank you um other questions
on retire health no all right let's go
on okay plant and property slide six if
you will um I'm discussing this
separately because it's a different
thing in terms of how we budget
um much like doit the maintenance of
buildings is something every agency
who's in a building pays
for there's a class 28 in their budget
and then the spend the the the
electricians the the the the work is in
our budget it's half of the rest of our
budget but it's very little general
funds it's 52 million in total funds and
6 million in
general because we build the other
agency so I'm going to use use one
example we do all the court
buildings and the the judicial branch
pays us about $1 million a
year General funds out of their budget
non-general funds in our
budget um we have 92 state buildings
including cour
houses we don't do any building where
people stay overnight on
purpose like uh Corrections New
Hampshire hospital
Etc um we we don't do ouses in the Parks
or the bathouses or things like that and
we don't do the mil Military
Reservation
so mostly we do Office Buildings mostly
in conquered we have about four between
four and 5 million square feet of office
space and conquered
Alone um so occasionally we refer to
people in buildings as tenants I would
never describe the legislature that
way um but and sometimes the the charge
is called rent but it's really an
allocated portion of the uh maintenance
cost
generally
um we do as much as we can to take care
of the buildings as best we can and and
the operative word is
triage um if we had an accurate deferred
maintenance list in the state it would
be about a billion dollars give or
take um and we're going to do two to
four million of that a year
so it obviously doesn't have to be that
accurate um but it it it just G gives
you a sense we're we're trying to do
more and we we every day think of new
ways to do things and are we you know
are cleaning contracts working better
than part-time building cleaners and
sometimes the market dictates that
sometimes it's dictated by who you can
get uh we actually have an enormous
amount of success right now with with um
own
staff mostly part-time building cleaners
and a lot of them happen to be in
conquered and from the refugee
communities um which works well
because people talk to each other and we
treat them
nicely and that's how you get people you
know where you should apply and so we
like that so that's plant and
property and that's that's the big piece
of
it oh there's a general fund component
to plant and property and it
it's we don't actually charge everybody
so the judicial branch is charged the
legislative branch is not and that shows
up as general funds the governor's
office is not charged that shows up as
general funds we don't actually Bill
ourselves except in a couple of small
cases because it would look weird um
although frankly I kind of think we
should but it would be a weird
accounting thing but so that's where you
see General funds and then non-state
enti
the legion we're required to give office
space to that's budgeted as general
funds um Humanities Council volunteer
New
Hampshire and somebody else I'm not
thinking of but anyway so that's the
general funds and then a very small
component in that division is uh the
state energy management office which is
100% General funds and Grant income so
is maybe this is an LBA question is is
this class 28 money um part of the
double counting money that's like doit
good it's the second biggest source of
double counting in the state gotcha
representative evil thank you um uh so
we spent an awful lot of time uh two
years ago talking about the new
legislative parking garage and the move
over to
um the I'm drawing like on what's the
name of the place Gran Place yeah right
Gran Granite place
um from a uh and it was it wasn't a
capital budget item it came through here
so I feel leg legitimate talking about
it how how's all could you just let us
know how that's going expenditure wise
um we bought Granite place the new doj
and agricultur is there and judicial
Council um and it got fixed
up um at a cost quite nicely if you've
been there probably the nicest State
Building um and that's not the standard
we put in most of our buildings but we
did there um so we now own it um we
bought it um six months ago I don't even
know anymore six eight months ago we
bought it we leased it briefly and then
bought it um so if you go over there we
own one Tower and we don't own the other
so um which is fine I'm not advocating
for anything
um the big hole on the ground over
there there
um it's going well it's um it it uh
right now it's as best as works so
before the Bank building that was doj
was there in
1958 um there was a school which is why
it's called School Street apparently and
a church and they buried them and uh and
when you dig up a site today the rules
for taking care of asvestas are slightly
different than they were in
1958 and slightly more expensive than
they were then so we've been doing
remediation there's drilling you might
have seen a whole bunch of granite that
was uncovered that all had to be taken
out washed and uh sold to somebody
who had use for it I don't know what it
was but um and so that's almost done and
we should be we should be pouring
footings for the garage um in a few
months and when we do it will go up
quickly it's like an Erector Set that's
sort of pre-assembled somewhere else and
then you come in and go and it goes up
so it it's going well and it's and it's
within
budget yeah so
um so then the legislature is still
planning on on moving over to the other
Tower it's the other Tower we're going
to at Granite place and are those all
legislative funds that are paying for
that or yes and not it's not we're not I
mean we're invol in the sense that we
help but it's uh it's your money right
okay and it's because of work being done
here and you'll go over there and then I
think a little bit of the second floor
of the annex and then store to the
construction zone so and then as soon as
the new legislative parking G What's the
timing on the store Street uh stores is
a decision that will be made after
everything else is done okay I think
when there's a new garage
the pathetic old garage will come down
but there's a cost to that right and
that'll be a decision
that um bigger heads than mine will make
thank you all right go ahead okay so I'm
going to talk about spending I'm
actually going to let Sherry who I think
is stopped coughing um go over our
spending by division and she's going to
talk to you about you know where we
spend and this is the non-plant property
non- retire Health quarter of our budget
and then she'll show
you um what went up and what went down
over the last six years so the next two
slides okay thank you good morning Sher
Rockburn assistant commissioner for the
department so slide seven is looking at
a snapshot today so fiscal
25 how does our department look in terms
of total funds and general funds so not
comparing to any trends of History just
a snapshot today where we spend our
money and within our department we have
about eight divisions so these are the
spend dollars by our divisions so talk a
little bit about our Commissioner's
Office commissioner's office um is not
just the three of us and you might think
if it was I may not be
here um but the commissioned office
includes um think about the the general
operations of a department so it
includes our HR department our business
office the state budget office is within
there um legal assistance is in there
proper and um um project management so
all of the sort of basic functions of
running a department are within that
that area
um accounting services that is our
Statewide Accounting Office so our state
comproller is the director of accounting
services they work primarily on
producing the audited um AER annual
comprehensive financial report that
office has um and payroll and payroll so
the next biggest piece of that is that
processes all the payroll for um state
employees so there's a payroll component
of that office it's the financial
reporting it manages all federal
reporting so federal government
Statewide um reporting comes out of that
area um as well as an internal or I say
an internal audit function but we look
at every payment voucher travel vouchers
things like that that also happen
Statewide so as we go through this what
you'll start to see is all the other
divisions within our department we're
really a central Service Agency so every
other agency touches ours through um
these divisions that I'm going to be
talking about so accounting services one
where every payment voucher gets um over
a certain dollar gets audited all the
payroll goes through that that area as
well you'll notice most of our divisions
as you start to see them is almost 100%
generally funds General funded uh Public
Works takes care of we build um we build
everything except for roads and bridges
which happened with Department of
Transportation so that office staffs um
Architects Engineers project management
so every construction project that it's
occurring in the state is managed by the
public works office and that's an area
where you'll notice that we have not
quite % General funds so where we can we
build other state agencies for the
oversight of those projects most of the
projects that they oversee are capital
projects um there are some smaller
projects that might get put in a regular
house bill one operating budget and we
manage manage that the RSA requires that
anything over 25,000 shall be managed by
the department um sorry the division of
Public Works there's a few waiver
opportunities for that there's a few
exceptions military fairs fishing games
parks and Parks dncr can manage their
own projects and there's more we didn't
want to go in detail on every little
thing we do as an agency and there's an
appendix which has every Division and it
includes some metrics for what exactly
they do but if you have any questions on
that we're happy to answer in great
detail on the mail room surplus food
pick something yeah um
are along those lines I've asked people
for sort of employee C
in in these various areas and we have
that in a few more slides okay so stay
tuned um Enterprise application
management uh we've heard towards our
deem division of Enterprise application
management formerly you might um have
heard fdm financial data management this
unit manages our state's accounting
system which we call New Hampshire first
so accounting payroll budgeting HR the
application itself is managed through
our office we do not manage the the
computers your your Windows operating
system things like that through
Department of Information Technology uh
commissioner goule we handle the um the
application the software behind it for
the accounting and
budgeting uh division of personnel dop
manages Statewide um hiring recruitment
um assist they have assist with
Collective uh bargaining Publications um
our classification system so as agencies
are looking to to look at their
positions their classifications do we
want to do a reclassification of a
position all of that flows through our
department of personnel you'll notice no
there's a little bit of gap between
total funds and general funds and what
that represents is our Bureau of
Education and Training we offer training
opportunities both the state employees
and those outside of the state the
outside of the state is primarily
municipalities but there's a training
program at a cost uh that we charg for
those training opportunities and then a
few years ago we stood up what was
called the HR suu human resource support
and for agencies that are small that
don't have a robust human resource um
office
those agencies can work with us and we
will manage that for them and we do a we
charge back um costs for that it's just
more of an allocation of our own staff
um but they may not be able to staff a
director of HR and two or three staff
and so they share um in that cost for us
to manage that for
them would it make sense to do that for
the whole All State departments and have
a call center and all that sort of stuff
um it's a it's a big question and
unfortunately the answer I'm going to
give you is maybe
um when we looked at this there's a
there's an argument for centralizing and
decentralizing
and the state's experience with
centralizing is the shared services
Center for AP and uh it went badly it
was just
everybody uh loan uh gave employees to
it that they would rather not
have and it did okay and it but it was
uh not as cost effective as people would
have hoped I don't know if HR would be
like that we we created the hru because
it seemed like a hybrid that for small
agencies it makes perfect sense now
we've recently added the judicial branch
which is not a small agency and so we're
experimenting with that and so I would
say I don't know I feel like HHS may
always have its own HR I mean h HHS has
more HR than
dop and so you've got 3,000 employees or
four and so the small ones definitely
and everybody I don't know I don't know
money and then the last two to talk
about plant property as commission o h
already already spoke about um
procurement and support services that's
really our our purchasing department
we manage contracts Statewide for
Commodities and that flows through that
office that office also helps manage the
contracts for sometimes what we call
single agency um services and contracts
so an agency will use our office as
assistance for something that might only
serve that one agency but most of the
work that goes through that office ends
up being Statewide contracts um and then
part of that office also includes our
purchase um sorry our plant and property
us white Farm as you think about it so
Surplus property
uh that is part of that office we have a
food surplus um division um in our mail
room graphic services so the non General
funds in that comes from a very small
amount a few hundred thousand of federal
money in our federal food program uh
graphic Services that's our charge to
other agencies mail room once again we
charge other agencies for the mail
services and um Surplus property self
Surplus property self-funded through
auction uh twice year so that's where
from thanks um so did I hear correctly
that um that you that uh you that you do
not handle procurement for All State
agencies it's just again it's the
smaller ones Sim similar to what you do
with HR
um similar but different um all legally
all Commodities have to go through
purchasing through US of any size so you
know I go to council with like eight
aggregate contracts that are technically
only used by
dot um but so all Commodities on service
contracts if it is a single agency
contract and it's
just um I'm hiring a carpenter to only
work on my building that an agency can
do itself if it's a Statewide contract
where we've determined that you're doing
it and you're doing it
we do a we do a global contract for the
state like like office supplies for
example is one of them that's more of a
commodity but service contracts that
everybody uses computer service
contracts so the idea is to is for bulk
purchasing I mean when it was created a
100 years ago it was to make sure that
various institutions bought together and
that's still the broad principle so some
of our contracts are
huge to follow up on um on the on the
chair's question about HR Services would
it make sense to
completely consolidate or centralize
procurement
it it might um I would say this
that we can't take it on with the staff
we have and that's why single agencies
were let uh were allowed to purchase
themselves I I think there would be some
advantages to it because we would have
more
consistent um we bid everything cuz
that's why we were created and not every
agency does and so that that would be an
advantage but I just want to warn you
that it would require staff and most
agencies except HHS don't have dedicated
necessarily contract or purchasing staff
so getting there um would be involved
at so just when you think you know it
all no I'm kidding um so you do actually
the Commodities purchasing for for do
for salt for aggregate for and so you
com they tell you sort of what you need
and then you do the bidding for it and
everything the way we buy everything is
that an expert develops a spec right the
specifications that they have to follow
salt is easier although more complicated
than you might think certainly more
complicated than I thought yeah it is uh
water content and things and then then
we bid and typically like on all
aggregate contracts dot is involved
heavily um but we do the purchasing and
usually in close contact with them but
yeah uh uh by law Commodities all have
to be bid by us okay and then I have a
another question so the Enterprise
application management um you it's
called New Hampshire first so is that
like I mean because I was having a
communication with folks from Bea they
were talking about New Hampshire first
is that a little bit I mean I know it
has a HR you mentioned aspect but does
that like the old one stop where
businesses could go and or you know it's
it's more like it's an Erp it's an
Enterprise platform and so if you think
about large companies mediumsized
companies
have one computer system that runs all
of their stuff so it all talks to each
other but it's HR it's payroll it's
Finance it's budget it's um it's
everything and so it is the primary
mechanism that every Finance person in
the state uses every HR person in the
state uses and every purchasing person
in the state
uses it all goes through that it's also
undergoing a a very significant upgrade
to the cloud it's an upgrade and we're
going to the cloud and it's but it is
the it is the computer backbone of the
operation of state government and and it
often referred to as an Erp okay so it
has nothing it's not like one stop at
all so even though he used that term
it's unrelated yeah correct and it may
be that they were referring to so for
example every single um payment to a
vendor is going to get uh paid through
New Hampshire first so they'll log on
they'll put their invoices in charge
think about is every payment whether
it's AP or payroll that gets charged
against the state budget goes through
that system so that system is loaded
with the budget as payments happen
against it it'll check for Budget
compliance are you going to overspend or
not that it's very specific class line
that all is flowing through that system
so the entire budget is in there think
of it as a very very very robust
QuickBooks you know think about people
soft um Oracle think about those types
of products that's what that is um our
current vendors in for um is the product
um the underlying product um Cloud Suite
is their their software their brand ship
name so that's what that system is it
doesn't
process um so Bea or gopher in terms of
arpa they used a separate system to
process applications for the Main Street
program that did not run through the
system so agencies have subsystems that
they might use for application purposes
in terms of applying for let's say a
grant or something like that that is
sort of outside the system but if you
think about every payment that is
happening and every collection Revenue
collection that's coming in is going to
funnel through there really to produce a
Statewide set of books Statewide
Financial so you think about your your
revenues your expenses you know in terms
of regular company all of that's going
to flow through the system so just one
other question um so we heard some just
on the iCloud migration I was on public
works for a really long time so I
remember a lot of the um original
software um purchases came through the
capital budget and then there was
licensing and all that stuff we heard
from Dr also that they're going to start
migrating to the cloud are you
considering that migration and then once
you're on the cloud the co related cost
operating costs I I mean is any of that
going to be reflected that we're going
to be talking about I mean and and this
may affect other agencies obviously
you'll see in in a later slide that that
we received arpa money to to to buy the
new implementation so to speak um I
think $15 million it's coming up and so
there's a capital component of the
upgrade of going to the cloud and all of
that the operating costs have always
been the the license if you will right
have always been in in the deem budget
and and still are are they going to go
up yeah cuz it's computers and I don't
know who got a hold of that but they go
up all the time Microsoft will get your
money one way or another but um but the
operating costs are there the the agency
operating costs are are there aren't
additional costs to them corre it's only
to us in in the implementation if they
have a subsystem that has to inter
interface into the system which they're
not supposed to and so if you do you
have to interface um they may have
development costs of redoing an
interface think of liquor for example um
but the operating costs are all in our
budget yeah 100% in our budget as
general funds we don't allocate that
cost back out to State agencies so we
pay that entire Bill ourselves well and
we'll have doit in here but I know that
there going to more of a subscription
model and there's there's a lot of stuff
going on yeah that's what this is too
when the the old system the on-prem
system is is going to not be supported
in
right well they said by the end of 24
but they're still supporting it so we'll
see okay you mentioned liquor are they
still um the gating item to finish the
end of the year report is that how's
that going are they still so liquor
didn't give you data for the end of the
year report their audit wasn't finished
or something right so lior's audit is so
I think there's a fiscal committee
meeting
tomorrow at which we will we have an
item requesting an extension of our
extension because we don't have liquor
and liquor is such a is a material piece
of the state books that our Auditors
have said if you don't have liquor you
can't have an opinion and that would be
bad really
really bad so um realistically we do
March okay so I'd like to turn over the
next slide uh slide eight this is now
looking at comparing our department so
funding 25 our current budget back to 19
and this is not set up by division I did
this one by our spend the type of spend
that's happening so if you look at the
bottom where it has the total
um in total we went up um about 2% total
funds so the general fund numbers at the
very bottom you'll see that but the the
gray section that says 152 150 2.3
million is our total fund increase from
19 to 25 and you'll see some significant
ups and downs in that so why overall we
went up 2% our salary and benefits alone
went up 31% in the next slide you'll
start to see our position counts
positions um change by about 14
positions over that six-year period so
quite flat so relatively flat that
increas is not the result of adding 30%
worth of positions uh most of that is
really the um significant pay raise that
occurred last year uh 10 10 and 2% but
uh so 9.7 million of an increase in
salary benefits um the other areas just
to point out so current expense think
about a lot of your operations one of
the big changes there that you'll um
that is going up there is we changed the
way we Bill and account for our mail
room so we previously it was more of a
net number because we Bild agencies so
the cost of all our postage was net
against the revenue that we charged
agencies um in the budget a few years
ago we had changed that from 19 so now
it shows the actual postage cost and
then the revenue coming in from State
agencies so net it's a zero zero number
in terms of that but the budgeting
presentation just looks a little bit
different there um our next era
utilities so Electric gas Etc um that
has surprisingly gone up a little bit
since 2019 um 1.8 million I will note
that we do have a footnote in our budget
that if we do not have funds
appropriated to sufficiently cover our
utilities we can go to fiscal for an
appropriation uh we don't do that often
but that is a um a footnote um that is
available to us if we need that um
you'll notice the next line and um
represent rire you had asked about the
027 so class 27 you refer to so our
class 27 that we paid doit um almost
doubled since 2019 so that's where that
is we don't have control over that
number that's their our share of their
their
budget okay um our next one down
equipment um and that one went um well
not significant in terms of total you
know total dollars it it had a
significant increase and that was
primarily the result of the annex and
downtown Renovations that are occurring
we needed to
um relocate staff out of the annex to
mostly main building and another state
office uh Pillsbury building in order to
do the renovation in the annex so we
moved as many people out as we could but
we needed to staff and uh equip those
offices in those areas so that cost was
there to help with that relocation of
staff and to also start to um purchase
some equipment for that for the actual
Annex itself um that project is very
much in its early stages of renovation
if you've been over we you walk under
scaling and things like that so that's
where that increase occurs this software
line this is um what we were just
talking about this is where we pay for
primarily our contract so you'll notice
that um there is a a slight increase
that occurred so software costs are
always going up the 26 27 that million
does grow when we move into the
subscription based um and I it grows to
about two
million um and we have a 30
I forget the 30-year contract with them
sort of looking at Charlie it's 20 I
think it's 15 15 sorry sry 15E um but
it's about so that'll will go up for
that
subscription the maintenance and
buildings and grounds so this um had a
significant increase for um this is all
the work that we do to maintain all the
buildings in the state in
200 uh
2021 an RSA was passed to charge
agencies 7 5 cents a square foot for
their office space so we could put money
into a non-aps deferred maintenance fund
um it has just a few million dollars in
it doesn't Harry very big balance it's
about 1.2 million a year that goes into
that but that is um to help with the
triage um if there's emergencies so that
is really the one of the big increases
between the two years is we had a new
deferred maintenance fund and the cost
of doe business is going up and we
invest as much as we can in terms of our
our buildings if the legislature gives
us six million we're going to do the
best to to triage if we have 1 million
we'll do the best so it's very um very
driven in terms of our budget and how
much we can do so in uh 2425 we had a
little extra that came our way and we we
appropriately worked with
that the but we do better at 6.7 than we
do at
3.2 as we say uh less buckets for leaks
the more we have um I'm going to talk
about the consultant and the contract
line in tandem with each other because
the million dooll increase about 7 to
900,000 of that increase is standing up
um paid family medical leave and Cassie
U is going to talk about that in a few
slides that was a brand new program that
came into play it's one of the few new
general fund programs that we've had in
our department and so we have a
consultant component of that new program
and a contract line that was helping
with um impl ation database website
marketing so most of that increase is
related to that program we'll talk a
little bit more but it was it's 100%
generally funded um it's about a million
dollar program so that was the increase
of increases Property and Casualty um
went down about 4.8 million over that uh
six-year
period represent thanks uh I'm I'm also
one of the newbies in this committee so
bear with me um the difference between
um total funds and general funds um I
understand that there's you know a lot
of that as like fees Etc is there some
kind of a Reconciliation that you have
that just says that explains where that
extra 90 million is coming from I can um
we can we can do one but let me give you
a sort of a snapshot retiree Health half
of the money is General funds and half
of it is self-funded state agencies
premium contributions and then a couple
of other fees like the like the medical
subsidy in the retirement system that we
charge so on that half of the
budget on plant and property it's all
money we charge other agencies the
difference between the six and the
52 that will show up in the budget as
agency income and it's what we charge
the agency for their their rent so to
speak the third biggest component is um
procurement and support services
purchasing purchasing is almost entirely
generally funded except for pecard
Revenue that is to say credit card usage
Revenue the other four units of that
division Surplus property almost
entirely federally funded graphic
Services um it's it's a few million
dollars and it's agency fees if you if
you do photoc copying or printing and we
do it for you you get charged if you
don't you don't um s Surplus property
it's it's agency income you they they
sell stuff you know that agency dispose
of what's the fourth oh the mail room
which is about 1.8 1.9 million is is we
charge agencies the mail room operates
on
the difference between first class mail
rate
and
sorting we take mail and we sort
it and you get a slight discount between
whatever stamps cost now I don't even
know anymore right 89 cents three three
bucks um and the little bit of money you
save that Arbitrage pays for the mail
room for the state so so so a lot of it
is you know kind of funny money because
there's an offset someplace else in the
budget that's for the plant
it's very much that it's double counted
Y for the other things it's it's a yeah
a little bit of that agencies pay if
they do it and don't if they don't right
if you don't have retirees you don't pay
retiree Health if you don't do Graphics
you don't pay graphic
fees we we can provide a a little bit
more detail but
there's probably I'm G to say maybe a
million or two but we don't really have
any M that comes from outside of the
state itself so if you think of the
state as one big box a lot lot of it is
moving around we're charging other
agencies very little like a few hundred
thousand is coming from federal grants
I'll do a you know but we can give the
detail we'll do a we'll do a cheat sheet
but like I said so there most of it is
within the state as opposed to a direct
to um an outside other than surplus food
you know y so you said um this Paid
Family Medical Leave thing is about a
million a year um it looks like there's
a fair amount of overhead on this right
this 300,00
consultant or whatever y so let's let's
move into that let me just do oh okay
you want yeah so one I let me do this
one so you Mr chairman you wanted three
things from us I think arpa funding what
do we do with that new programs which is
pfml
and and positions and that's what we're
going to do next quickly three slid so
just really really quick represent blman
have a question first yeah he does thank
you Mr chairman
good good to see you all so going back
to plant buildings Etc I was over in the
gallon Park just a day or two ago and I
noticed there's still a number of
decaying sadl looking buildings what are
we doing with
them um I can tell you what we're doing
with each of them but broadly um so the
one the kind of Victorian looking one
next to the main building is the main
building the oldest building a little
building and then a kind of Victorian
looking bankr we stabilized if we ever
get money in the capital budget we're
going to fix it but right now we've
stabilized it so it doesn't turn into
Laconia the the things on the back of
the main building like the Kent wing for
example is so far gone it looked it cuz
it looked like all the windows have been
we don't let anyone in and and I I
toured it like six years ago and someone
said don't look around look down and if
the floor looks like it'll cave in it
will and and um the problem is the
capital budget has $120 million in it
and if I want 2.6 million to tear down a
building everyone says call me next year
and so we're doing the best we can but
um mostly we're just trying to to take
stuff off to make them safe okay thanks
thanks Mr
chairman so the next arpa yeah so the
next slide which is our arpa funding and
then I'll turn it over to Cassie for the
pfml we can talk about that we received
um about 75 million in arpa funding and
it it was for onetime use and most of
our 75 million you can look at as
onetime construction we received about
33 million that was HVAC related for our
buildings and then a a second bucket of
money for deferred maintenance so we
split it really between HVAC systems
versus everything else going on with the
buildings um that was U most of the
money that weeded for arpa and those
project projects that were ongoing so
this money has been 100% committed um
and obligated before December 31st um a
few weeks ago that was the arpa deadline
and then those projects some of them are
completely done some of them are in the
works and we have until December of 26
in the arper program to make sure those
are fully spent so that was where that
occurred there's no additional General
funds or ongoing costs associated with
those um the second bucket we received
was uh as commissioner Charlie Al had
mentioned was for our New Hampshire
first that's our Erp system 15 million
of the upgrade this is not for ongoing
operations this was really the
implementation and the upgrade from um
the last time we had done anything was
um many many years ago so this was
working with the vendor um to upgrade
that system to the latest
platform okay and then the last piece on
very small dollars but very very
important was we set up a Statewide
recruitment unit in the division of
personnel and what we realized uh
especially in the pandemic era and
coming out of that
is just saying that there's a state job
and the state's really great to work for
wasn't enough to recruit um skilled and
qualified workers you know I think for a
very long time it was a um it didn't
need marketing on its own um people came
to the state for great quality of life
and great health benefits and as the
market really changed and the workforce
changed at the start of the pandemic we
realized the the criticality of trying
to maintain a Workforce so this this was
money that was stood up um and what we
used for it primarily was um I'll call
it uh platforms or tool kits uh indeed
um things like that um Lin LinkedIn
handshake handshake so I didn't even
know about handshake Char and I talked
about is is
uh know what they are I'm proud of we
were like is monsters still exist but
you know so we were dating ourselves a
little with the with the the things is
coming in so this was a program um in
the beginning of this arpa um HHS
Department of Health andar had gone out
to ask for arpa money to stand up a
recruitment unit just for them and I
want I believe it was at a fiscal
committee they asked us to work together
to stand up a Statewide unit so it
wasn't just one agency so that's what
that unit became um and so that's that's
what's happening there um in terms of
where does it go in the future and what
we tried to do is our division of
personnel has always had staff to to
work on recruitment what we've done is
is in the future budgets it's not that
we've grown our budget in any sort of
way we just changed the way we do
business so this helps stand up that
model um in terms of how we do business
I don't know okay yeah I think it's fair
we have to absorb it yeah so the other
thing you wanted to know is what new
programs have been established in the
last six
years not very many but there's
one hi again um so in 2021 uh House Bill
2 established paid family medical leave
in New Hampshire it was a a first and en
model for a voluntary pfml program and
um the way the law uh set up our program
was it required the state to purchase
Paid Family Leave insurance for all
state employees and I'll go back and
talk about paid family versus paid
family medical leave anyway the purpose
was to create a market right to so to to
to incentivize an insurer to come in and
to provide the insurance for state
employees and then to administer the
voluntary aspect of the plan it's
voluntary because employers get to
decide very differently from other
states that have done this whether they
want to purchase Paid Family Medical
Leave insurance for their employees or
if they don't if they decide they want
to they can decide um what coverage they
want to um buy base coverage or there
are some buy up options the the basic
benefit is six weeks of wage replacement
benefits at 60% of the salary so um
employers can buy up to 100% or they can
buy more weeks up to 12 weeks um and
then recognizing that it's a voluntary
program that employers can either
participate in or not if my employer
decides I'm not I'm not buying that I
can as a worker in New Hampshire say I'm
going to purchase this for myself myself
and I can go to the individual market
and purchase that coverage for myself
and the law caps that at $5 a week for
an individual so it keeps the the um
cost as reasonable as possible for
individuals
um just so you know it's it's paid
family leave for state employees because
it complements already existing benefits
we have and we have a really robust
income protection plan if an employee
gets um said say catastrophically ill we
we provide coverage for up to six months
so so this is the plan it was brand new
here let me tell you some other things
about the plan um first of all Das and
NH Employment Security were charged with
implementation in New Hampshire we had a
four-person implementation team it was
me Rich labers Deputy Commissioner at
nhes um um and project management staff
in my office so four people we were one
time on a call with um other states that
were implementing um paid family medical
leave and we were listening to States
talk about um well we hired a hundred
people blah blah blah blah blah right
four people I want to make that point
okay so so let there there um there are
some usual aspects to the law and it
gets to the the expenses right so the
law authorized us to um to establish a
budget and to um hire consultants and it
also imposed on the state the obligation
to Market and Outreach the plan okay so
we um stand up the program by going out
to bid for different kinds of contracts
but let me just start with the carrier
our carrier is Met Life a fortune 200
company okay with a blimp with a blimp
and we're paying for marketing and
Outreach
okay so that's one thought um we also
have a contract with a consultant that
um so what did we we had to build this
from the ground up and so we have a very
robust website if you look at nh.gov
there's a very prominent button it
brings you to our website you'll see
it's very comprehensive wonderful tools
for employers individuals it's uh
there's a quote calculator it's great um
but we have we have an obligation under
the law to do an annual report we we
have to remember remember I talked about
carriers and you have to manage them we
have to work with metti we have to like
work with them every single month to
validate the data right so there's a lot
of there's a lot of work that goes on
behind the scenes and and truthfully um
we've moved on to other important
priority projects and and our consultant
helps us survive okay um and we have a
very tiny contract for the website
itself and that's where the company
called silvertech from Manchester you
folks may have heard of it so MetLife
marketing consultant and and um and the
website uh one thing that I forgot to
mention on the slide I'm sorry I saw it
La at last night um the law
also established an incen for employers
to participate and it provides for a
50% bet tax credit of the cost that the
employer pays for the coverage so so if
I pay 100% as the employer then I get a
tax credit of 50% if I only pay 50% then
I'm I'm not able to take my tax credit
for the portion the employees pitching
it okay um so when you look here at the
chart at the bottom of the page what you
see in 22 and 23 is is that's really our
implementation period and
implementation um continued even while
we got the program stood up and got it
running right and so um we we
implemented and you can see our
appropriation and our expenses and then
if if you look compare uh 23 to 24 you
can see that um we we dropped our
expenses and that's because because we
had already done a substantial amount of
sort of the marketing material to to St
to stand up the program and working with
our marketing vendor um we we kind of
right-sized what we were asking them to
do for us based on uh how they performed
and and we and we began focusing very
intensively in in New Hampshire so we've
done a ton of Outreach we've talked to
Chambers of Commerce we've talked to the
Bia um I like to say this they don't
want to talk to us anymore about this
right they've heard it all um but we
have a commercial on on WM I've I I I've
had that Dreadful cold everybody has and
I've seen it four times in the last
couple of weeks right it's very it's
well well done we have some really great
um radio spots by the way there are
three radio spots in one commercial and
we continue to run them we're not doing
new commercials we're not doing new
radio spots right uh we have paid search
we we're on social media um at the least
viral campaign I've ever seen by the way
I've always like to say um we've done
newspaper ads we do radio interviews Etc
so um I'll let you ask me questions
represent Griffin has a question uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I remember at the time that
we were working on this family leave
that we made the provision for an
individual to take it yes what I don't
remember number is does the employer
have to deduct for the
individual so if it depends on the size
of the company that I work with what
what the employer's obligations are if
the in if one of their workers goes to
the individual marketing and covers and
basically it's large employer small
employer right so if I'm a large
employer under the law the obligation is
is that if I have an employee whose
purchase coverage on the individual
Market I actually have to withhold the
premium
from their their pay and I have to send
it to to metti um a an individual with
who works for a large employer has job
protection as they do under federal law
um if if I'm a small employer I do not
have to withhold and send in for my
employee I might make arrangements to do
that it might be the employee um and
there is no job protection for small all
employer
employees how is $5 enough for this
benefit I mean that seems like a
ridiculous it it's um it's it's close
right so um part of the whole um think
about what I was talking about how we
stood up the program we pay for state
employees to incentivize a carrier to
come into the market and to create the
market that is that that um expenditure
I think it was $1.6 million in um in
$1.45 two million in 24
okay that that is helping to maintain
the profitability of the program for the
carrier and and is a big part of their
willingness to stay
here how much per how much per state
employee are we paying um let well yes
please do um so in every agency's budget
as part of their salary and benefit line
so in the benefit line where there's um
as an employer we pay uh taxes it's less
than 1% of the person's salary and it
ends up being
0.027 it's in the middle of the slide um
so it's less than 1% multiplied by an
employees wages so that's what that and
that across the entire State ended up
being about1 and a half million dollars
a year that the state pays
um to the carrier but can you express it
in dollars per week or per
employee it's zero yes I'm going to do
this if it's about 1 of 1% so if you
make a 100 Grand which not that many
people
make 1% of a 100 Grand is a $100 or
$1,000 02 is
$200 a year so per pay period it's less
than $4 a week yeah yeah so okay all
right so first representative Lehman
then representative
W thanks Mr chairman I'm just curious
how many people have taken advantage of
this program and how many people are are
on it right now well so all state
employees right um we have 286 employers
who who have um a total of
11,500 employees who are eligible to co
for coverage so remember I said that
employers can say you have to contribute
so an employer may have an employee who
decides not to contribute therefore not
buy so actual individuals covered
through employers 600
6,964 this is as of September 30th we
have
1152 individuals who have purchased as
of
93024 by the way the individual Market
has an annual open enrollment period
it's established in the law and very
informally I will tell you that um it
just closed um January 29th and the
individuals participating is up to I
realize that someone might look at it
and say oh oh is that all right so I say
I I like to say this here's the thing
it's voluntary right and and the thing
about it being voluntary is it's
voluntary right so so it
I thought I heard the question asked but
I didn't hear the answer how many people
in a year have taken advantage of this
program so so I what I did is I broke it
down by how many through employers and
how many through the individual market
so as of September 30th
6,964 are covered through
employers and um
1152 individuals and I I have some early
reporting that would need to be
validated that uh we just finished open
enrollment and so the number in of
individuals has jumped to
1681 but I'm wondering how many in a
year like is it 10% 20% oh good you mean
how many have accessed a benefit right
um I can get you that information okay
and and they don't when they go out on
this they don't get their full pay they
get like 60 60% yeah that's what I
recall so it's there is some loss of pay
this isn't a freebie that you just oh
I'm going to take an extra vacation no
and and by the way um for these kinds of
plans it's good to pay less than 100%
because it incentivizes people to come
back to work very good thank you but I
would expect that the individuals can
you can you see how much the individual
Market accesses it versus the others
because like I would assume of all state
employees very few the percentage of all
state employees who use the benefit who
receive the benefit is low but the of
the individual Market which are ones
that decide I need this I'm I assume it
would be much much higher yes it is and
and um so I have some um first of all if
I if if I may I can send you our annual
report and I have a report that we just
gave there's an Advisory Board um and so
I have all that claim data I I I'm sorry
I didn't prepare for it today it's a lot
okay um so I can show you the state
employee claims I can show you the
employee your claims right and I can
break out individual Market by the way
um a big utilizer of the plan is young
babies thank you all right why don't we
move on the last thing and I think this
is what you're all waiting for is
positions uh slides 11 and 12 and then
after that there's an appendix of who we
are and what we do everywhere but 11 and
12 um this is meant to show you that
we're relatively flat at the bottom
fiscal 19 321 we added four positions in
that budget two of them were at dop two
of them were in Enterprise
management for the ARP um in the next
budget which if you remember was the
budget where we we had hearings in
socially distant hearings at
do um we got one position that's the
business office position um to respond
to the number of attached boards that we
have and the work that they require um
sponsored I should say that amendment by
representative Ober um who we hope is
watching um in the 23 budget we got uh
nine positions or the 23 into the
current budget and and here's what they
are so two of them were purchasing
agents um we're now required to take
almost every purchasing contract to
council
because the council wants to see a lot
more than they used to and that's
nothing that anyone has control over
except five
councilors but it's a lot more work so
we got two purchasing agents uh two more
workers at dop and uh agencies will tell
you that they worry about the slowness
of
um HR transactions and we're trying
we've gotten so much better in the last
uh since Lori rudus started actually in
2018 but um it's a lot of work we did
not have a safety officer for plan and
property we added one I would do that
again um and then we bought two new
buildings and each of them has a worker
at them I mean we have a lot of workers
who cover a lot of buildings but you
can't buy a building and not have a
person and so that's what those are um
and then building service worker are the
cleaners and we've had a lot of a lot of
cleaners are part-time and we had a lot
of struggle hiring when Dunkin Donuts
was was paying better cuz you don't have
to clean toilets at Dunkin' donuts and
um we' done some moving around to
part-time positions and eight
part-timers became two full-timers but
that's a it's a net zero but it's there
in our agency
budget um we added no positions and we
unfunded 28 positions I'll tell you a
little bit about where that is um and
it's in bold and in all capitals because
it's painful as all get out um because
everything we do affects everybody and I
don't have anyone who works for me who
is
underworked um so if you look at the
next page it'll show you kind of kind of
where that is uh plant and property um
again minimal General funds
um they will eliminate very few
positions in their budget because we'll
probably try to make up with contract
work by doing it with own with people we
have um so that's that risk has no
General funds um so and that's 18
positions but the 28 positions all come
out of the rest of operations and and
it's almost all General funds except
some graphic Services money um and it's
big and you can see in the other two
charts what that means um if you look at
our efficiency number in the bottom box
um you can see by the arrow that the 180
um ties to this
number and um how many are vacant how
many are filled and and you can probably
figure out that 28 unfunded positions
when you don't have 28 vacant
positions is something that we're still
working on trying to avoid
doing um and it's a priority because we
don't have a lot of like I say I don't
have a unit of six that I think should
be four
I have a lot of units of six that I
think should be eight um our vacancy
history is in the other other chart and
it's just point in time it's gotten
better I I will make a point about
government the state hires a lot of
people and loses a lot of people so when
our numbers go up you know in a in a
given year we'll hire 15 16, 1800 new
people there's a churn and a lot of
people leave state government and it's
sort of like the jobless numbers
nationally when people say oh the the
the country added 300,000 new jobs no it
didn't it added 31 million new jobs and
it lost 30.7 million new jobs and the
net is that so in state government
there's a churn and it contributes to
vacancies if if you say to me
me well you got a vacant position you're
you're not using it now well no but you
know he left and then we hired him and
then she left and we hired her and then
and there's this churn that goes on
constantly I have 300 full-time
positions and I hire a 100 people a
year and now building cleaners there's a
lot more insuring because it's low wage
part-time um accountants there's a
little less churn but there's
churn anyway that's where we are in
positions I think we're relatively lean
that's my story and I'm sticking to it
thank you all right final questions from
the committee I'm not seeing any all
right well thank you very much thanks
for having us we'll see you in a few
weeks and you'll get me some language
for my bill very shortly job today all
right thank you very much thank
you yes thank you all right um why don't
we take a very short recess and come
back at
retirement
e
10:40 I'm trying to teach teach these
salt
all
right
yeah okay so let's get started and
right yes um thank you very much Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is Jan Goodwin and I'm the executive
director of nhrs with me to my right is
Marie Mullen our Chief Financial Officer
and to my left is rald LEC our chief
investment officer and before you you
should have a presentation that looks
like this
yes great okay as you can see on page
two we'll be covering a broad range of
topics this morning page three is
information that probably most of you
are very familiar with that were
contributory multi-employer defined
benefit plan established in
1967 we provide a wide range of benefits
that are related to retirement or
disability for our
members and the pension benefits are
funded through employee and employer
contribution and investment income and
typically it's the investment returns
benefits on page four nhr r s is a
component unit of state government and
is very different from most state
agencies that come before you as we are
not at all funded by the general fund we
are overseen by a Board of Trustees the
current list of board members is on page
43 of your
presentation and we also have an
independent investment committee and
both the board and the independent
investment committee are
fiduciaries and you as you all know are
our and sponsor the responsibility of
nhrs staff is to implement the statutes
that you pass as well as the rules and
the policies that are promulgated by our
board and in addition to um those rules
we also have to follow the Internal
Revenue code established by the IRS um
because we want to ensure that at all
times we maintain our qualified plan
status there are various constitutional
Provisions that benefit us one of them
is article 36a which protects our funds
for the exclusive purpose of providing
benefits which means they cannot be
diverted for any other
purpose and it also requires that the
board certify employer contribution
rates based on sound Actuarial practice
and also those employers are required to
pay the rates that are
certified and these constitutional
Provisions help ensure that nhrs remains
on the path to 100%
funding page
five this is the basic equation that
makes all pension plans work that over
time contributions and investment income
have to equal the benefits and the
expenses that are paid by the
plan it relies on one of Albert
Einstein's most important conclusions
the compounding of interest is the
eighth wonder of the world and that's
what makes pension plans
work as of June 30 our assets were 12.3
billion
and and as of November 30th they were at
12.9
billion the chart on the next page shows
you that our assets are continue to be
on a good trajectory climbing upward
page seven gives you um some overview of
some different projects that we've been
working on our pension application
upgrade is nearly complete this is
something that we started in 2019 it was
a multi-year project and we're very glad
to have implemented it we have also made
updates to the Strategic asset
allocation plan we continue to recognize
the Cyber threats that apply to all
public entities especially public
pension plans so much confidential
information so we're constantly making
sure that we have everything up to date
we've also been improving our education
and Outreach for members employers and
the general public we have a new
five-year strategic plan for the
investment office that was spearheaded
by our chief investment officer rald LEC
and we've also increased the efforts to
um enhance the number of members using
my account we are now we now have 31,000
members using that online portal and now
I will turn to Marie Mullen who will
give you some updates from the finance
side of our house good board EMB of
committee uh with regards to finance we
recently had our um pgb 3 implementation
as the Director had stated um during
that time frame we identified um some
areas where we need to improve on the
employer side so um we made a structural
change in in our employer reporting
group where we assigned the employers to
a specific nhrs relationship manager so
that they had one point of contact for
any issues that they had with their
reporting payments reconciliation of
their accounts this has aided greatly um
it's been very well received by the
employers and has really been um aided
greatly excuse me after we've gone um
through the implementation to be able to
assist them with some of the challenges
that may have been out there we we
implemented some employer listening
sessions so we had employers come tell
us what they like and didn't like about
the new system what things we could
improve on what might have been missing
uh so we we have initiated new reporting
we have initiated some additional
functionality in the system to assist
the employers so we've made some of
those changes as
well um we also continue to en enhance
our uh dashboards and Reporting
internally so that at all times we know
where we are with the employers who has
reported who hasn't reported who is paid
who hasn't paid so that we can maintain
the collections we can identify training
that is needed maybe with these
employers and any issues that they need
having um also in finance we're also
working on some investment fee um
transparency so we're looking to um make
some changes within our system and our
processes to improve that transparency
break out those fees a little more um a
little more in detail so that we can
provide that trans Arcy so we have some
projects ongoing at this time during the
Spring to be able to do that and then
we're also looking to do a financial
software upgrade our financial software
um is separate from the pension Software
System and that we've had that for seven
or eight years um and we're looking to
do an upgrade for that coming next year
all right I see questions from
representative
cell thank you Mr chair um what would
you say is a delinquency rate among C uh
that you have and what percentage of
overall collections would that
constitute if if more more or less uh
delinquency rate I would say is is about
uh 10% right now we they are required to
pay so we do um get the collections and
we do they do pay like everyone does pay
so it sometimes it can be a little
delayed by a month or two but we do
follow up and make sure that they have
paid and we're re we're always
reconciling their accounts to make sure
that they they have paid so it's nothing
that has been outstanding for years or
months and months it's we're we're
always uh doing that collection and they
are required to you welcome so from your
point of view
is municipalities school districts etc
those are all Employers in the state is
is the state as a whole one employer or
is HHS an employer and Corrections an
employer and all that sort of thing um
thank you for the question yes um the
state is one employer except for some of
the component units so nhrs is a
separate employer P's some of the
component units are separate employers
thank you um but the state as a whole
employer thank you Mr chair along those
lines what percentage of the
participants are employed um like
nonstate entity employers like how many
what percentage are employed by
municipalities and um like schools towns
fire departments whatever yes so
approximately 20% of the members are
state employees and the other 80% make
up the municipality state police fire
that type thing not I don't mean State
of New Hampshire police fire I mean
police and fire across the state so I
would assume almost 50% are school
districts yes or no um I don't have that
number of the top of my head but I can I
that yeah here it is well 20 is State
it's on page 18 we we don't have it um
Broken Out by percent but we have it as
um state employees are I'm sorry the
employee Group which includes state
employees as well as Municipal and
county is is almost 50% of the total
membership and teachers are almost a
third
you all right uh thank you with that
I'll turn it back over to executive
director thank you Marie um I'm now on
page nine of the presentation um we are
going to be getting a new building the
background is is that our current lease
we are currently we've been in leased um
space for um for quite a long time uh
currently expires in March of 2026 and
we needed to provide our notice of
renewal or non-renewal to our land lord
by May of this year so what we did is
our board chair appointed four board
members to act on an ad hoc real estate
committee and five staff members
including the three of us um supported
their work we engaged the broker kushman
and Wakefield to review lease and
purchase options in central New
Hampshire to find the most cost
effective Office Space over the long
term for nhrs staff so we can con
continue to provide great customer
service to our members retirees and
beneficiaries we took a total cost of
occupancy approach and considered all of
the costs of renting and owning to make
an informed decision so after a
comprehensive review of lease and
purchase options the board approved into
entering a contract for purchase we've
also conducted thorough due diligence
including site assessment building
condition and title search and no
material exceptions were noted on page
10 is a summary of where we currently
are we're in leas space and conquered at
54 Regional drive and our new address
will be 80 Commercial Street which is
part of the Corporate Center at
Horseshoe Pond so you can see there'll
be very easy access um for our members
because of the the different major roads
that run through there and the total
purchase price is $5 million we expect
March you're
welcome page 11 is significant um
developments since 2007 one of the most
important ones as you're very well aware
of is in 2010 was the 30-year
amortization of our unfunded
liability and since then the unfunded
liability has grown largely as a result
of changes in our assumed rate of return
as you can see on this page the board
reduced the rate of return three times
since
6.75% and the reason why that's
important is that the assumed rate of
return is the discount rate that is
applied to our liabilities to determine
the pr present value of our liabilities
so the lower the assumed rate of return
the higher the liabilities and that also
means the higher the employer
contribution rates are
chaires um thank you and thank you for
taking my question could you just
briefly touch on the change in Actuarial
methodology that happened in 2007 I know
that was pretty significant yes I can
let me just get the details on that in
front of
me there were a number of changes that
happened around there one of the key
ones
was changing the um actual Actuarial
method we had originally used open group
aggregate to determine our liability and
now we've replace that with the entry
age
normal the open Group aggregate had
provided um for a much lower unfunded
liability and artificially low employer
contribution
rates I don't know that they all have
and what is the what is the new approach
or we we have since 2008
um um we've been using the entry age
normal which is consider to be more
Community all
okay page 12 um these next few pages are
a summary of different benefit changes
that have occurred since 2020 they've
been in a
combination of two different categories
the first is ad hoc inflation protection
for retirees and
beneficiaries and the second category is
restoration of group two benefits that
were reduced in
2011 so um I won't go through the
details of all of these different pieces
of legislation so that's Pages 12 12 and
15 and then 16 was the last one um that
was passed in 2016 and we are right now
in the process of getting ready to
implement the change in the multiplier
members page 17 nhrs membership covers a
broad range of public employees
throughout New Hampshire our members are
divided into two groups one is group one
which covers employees which are state
employees City and Municipal
Employees as well as teachers as the
other group in group one and then group
two is is the police and the and
fire we have 468 active participating
employers the largest single exception
of membership is the city of Manchester
employees but we do cover their teachers
police and fire
employees so the word teachers this also
includes other Schoolboard employees
right I mean school
nurse um and things like that yes or no
um thank you very much Mr chair um
typically no because the person has to
be a certified teacher in order to be a
teacher they would be just a regular
employee okay so they'd be a group one
employee they would still be group one
but they would not be a teacher all
right thank you it depends if they're
certified or not so a principal is
required to be certified so a principal
is a teacher would be considered a
teacher a superintendent might be a 12
month employee gotcha all right thank
you representative
R I'm piggybacking on a lot of your
questions Mr chair so thank you for them
so following up to that question so
let's say a par educator that's in a
school district they would be or
custodian they would be um in um they
would be considered an
employee that's correct because they
don't have that
certification okay so is it only state
certification what if there's a national
what if there's a position where
someone's nationally certified but not
State Certified would they be any
situations like that um is it just a en
certification um Mr chair members of
committee representative FR there's
state certification for educators and to
my knowledge there is not a national
certification for educators all right
thank
you
okay page 18 um this shows the breakdown
between our active members um which
group they're in and which
classification they're in as well as uh
what our retirees and
beneficiaries are like and we also have
some basic demographic information for
active members the average age is a
little bit under age 46 and a little bit
under 11 years of service in contrast
our retirees average agees is 72.2 and
their average benefit is a little bit
over
$21,000 page 19 as you can see in fiscal
year 24 we cross the $1 billion
threshold in retirement
benefits with paid to retirees and
beneficiaries and in addition we also
paid close to 40 million in the
post-retirement medical subsidy and this
$1 billion dollars is very important to
New Hampshire not just to the
individuals who receive it but to the to
the communities that they live in nearly
80% of our retirees and beneficiaries
remain here in New Hampshire and these
payments have a significant impact on
the local economies throughout the
state page 20 shows the benefits um by
County how much goes into each one as
you would expect in the more rural
counties there's lower amounts whereas
the more urban Counties have
significantly higher amounts of pension
benefits
going page 21 shows the four types of R
retirement our members can have service
disability early invested deferred and
there are different benefit
Provisions applying to group one and
group two
members and there's also different
benefit Provisions that are applied
based on the vested status and the date
of hire and we now have three tiers of
members following the 2011
legislation our pension benefits are
determined by a a formula that consists
of three components how many years of
service does the member have their
average final compensation and then our
benefit multiplier and all of this
varies with the different um member
tiers and
groups page 22 shows that we have a very
modest benefit that our members get you
can see how the group one retiree
benefits compared to those in group two
an important distinction between group
one and group two is that the group two
Public Safety members do not participate
in Social Security and so that's a
significant reason why their retirement
one page 23 shows a breakdown
of the how high the different benefits
are as you can see over 2third of our
retirees have a pension benefit of less
than
$25,000 page
24 as wonderful as cost of living
adjustments colas are to retirees and
beneficiaries they are very
prefunding employer contribution ution
rate and that is why the legislature
typically when it makes a cost of a a a
temporary supplemental allowance they
prefunds as well correct exactly it
covers all the all all of the members
page 25 shows what the member at
contributions are as you can see they
they are set in statute and do not
change in contrast the employer
contributions are actually determined
and that by our actuaries and then
certified by our trustees on a bial
basis and the timeline for this is shown
on page 52 of the
presentation since 20
local employers have paid 100% of the
employees and in fiscal year 22 the
legislature provided a one-time State
reimbursement for a portion of the local
employer contributions and there is
session representative evil just follow
up though on on your question Mr chair
so even though the current state
contribution is zero was the point you
were making that when there's a cola or
a supplemental payment that goes to
everybody even though we pay zero for
the benefit is that what you were trying
to get
at um I I I think the point that the
chair was making is
that the state when it's made
Appropriations to cover
um temporary supplemental allowances has
has paid the money out of the general
fund rather than look to the individual
employers for the people who had worked
for them and are now getting the
temporary supplemental allowance I think
that was the point that the chair was
making I got yeah I can answer but
representative wer yeah the biggest
difference in what we contribute to to
retirees when we used to have to
contribute 35% to municipal employees
and County employees and so on there was
no way to judge what that would cost
we're trying to look 27 months in the
future and say what will it cost us in
the budget if we just say okay we'll
give 35% to whatever you do and they
typically are putting more employees on
more pay raises all these things we
couldn't predict and when we took it
away in 2012 it was going it was moving
up from like going to be 120 million ion
over a 2-year period up from and that
was a big standard increase over what
had had been the previous biennium
there's no way we could set a budget
where we contribute whatever whatever
you do we'll give
35% that that could be totally unknown
and even when we gave this 7 and a half%
it it made virtually no difference in
anybody's tax rate we gave 100 million
back in
2023 from Statewide education property
tax should have saved a couple hundred
dollar per taxpayer nobody even saw it
it just went away with the with the
school increases so there there's you
have to be able to predict when we say
we'll give 500 to this one 500 that one
we know what that is we know that that
that group is and we could put a number
in there we're making a budget that
budget has to go for two years we can't
do it if we're paying whatever it is you
need we're going to put it in there we
can't do that
because we don't have the revenue yeah
so so the other point that I was sort of
making was she used the word pre prepaid
meaning that we ask them if we give this
benefit what's the cost of it to the
fund right now right what what's the the
current cost there have been cases in
the past where the where the legislature
gave a cola but didn't put any money
into the fund right all they did was let
the unfunded liability increase and and
then in that case it's on all the
employers that Cola right because they
all have part of the unfunded liability
whereas when we prepay it's only on the
state coffers and not on towns and
schools and all that stuff no not quite
yeah all right goad the cola came out of
the Surplus that was in the
fund and it and when we had Surplus in
the fund we could sit there and decide
okay we can give and group two would
have a different Surplus than employees
group group one and I remember a friend
of mine that was in group two you never
give us as much as the teachers well the
teachers had more Surplus because the
average teacher seven and seven years
plus just enough to get uh funded and
then they left whereas police would be
15 20 years firemen stayed on for
Generations so there was very little Sur
Surplus in the fire Surplus came in the
teachers union because the teacher
contributing the employers contributing
the teacher leaves they take what they
got what they put in but the rest goes
into the fund that's how the fund gets a
surplus more in the teachers than in the
other ones so although people make
claims the numbers don't back them up
I've been listening to these for years I
might argue that prior to this um
accounting change you know you may have
thought you had a surplus but in reality
you didn't right so true anyways all
right representative rang and then we'll
get back on track okay thank you Mr
chair so um I'm kind of curious about
what is the benefit to
municipalities um in joining the state
retirement fund I mean obviously there
was a benefit to the state retirement
fund because they
initially contributed to the uh the
premiums but um I'm just wondering since
those have gone away what is what is the
benefit to the retirement system of
having these Municipal
Employees and
um I guess that that's my question well
I would say that the benefit to the
municipal and County employers is that
the pension benefit it for most public
employees is a significant part of their
compensation and by having nhrs
administer it rather than each
individual city or town in the state of
New Hampshire having to administer their
own pension
benefit that there's a considerable
administrative savings on the part of
the different public Employers in the
state of New Hampshire okay followup Mr
chair and then what's the benefit to the
retirement system of having those
municipalities participate in it um
Retirement Systems depend on having more
me U on having a good pool of members so
that there's always members retiring new
members being hired so that there's a
steady flow of contributions in to
offset the steady flow of contributions
out uh
but um that said there's also we have a
substantial Corpus of in Investments
we've got close to you know the 11.9
billion at the end of November so our
benefits are essentially pre-funded so
even though the money in and the money
out in any year could be very similar we
still continue to grow because the
assets are growing so that we because we
because we attempt to pre fund the the
benefits okay thank you so would you
might also say that having more people
in the system spreads out the expenses
over a larger group of people like like
your $5 million building and things like
that yes exactly okay yes let's continue
page uh was it 26 I guess yes
26 so every two years consistent with
statute we do a an Actuarial valuation
which um calculates our funding status
and we also use these valuations to
emplo to establish our employer
contribution rates the contribution
rates has three components there's the
normal cost there's the payment to
amortise the unfunded liability and then
there's also the medical subsidy and
each employer employee each member group
has a separate contribution rate and all
of this is all of these contribution
rates are based on the assumptions that
were dered in the most recent experience
study and we do experience studies every
four years we just completed one that
covered um TW fiscal years 19 through
2023 and we were very pleased that the
assumptions all basically held up we did
not have to reduce the Actuarial rate of
return as we had in the three previous
experience studies and so we did not
have a an increase in our unfunded
liability because we did not have to Inc
because we did not have to decrease the
Actuarial rate of return Mr chair yes
present uh thank you for taking my
question again uh I've got I've got
three that are hopefully quick um the
when you were we just got had a
presentation from the Department of
administrative services and they talked
a lot about the retiring medical program
that they administer the medical subsidy
is there is there a connection I mean is
this is this money that they then that
then Das you know is responsible for
administering no um um Mr chair members
of the committee representative Ms the
medical subsidy is only for
certain members who
were active members in approximately
2,000 so it's a it's a small group of
people and it's growing smaller okay
thank you and then the other two
questions when's the last time that the
um member contributions were
changed I believe that was in two
2011 okay so that so then that being the
case um any increase in
um the the cost is reflected in the the
banial Actuarial valuation that's really
been absorbed by the employers correct
Mr chair members of the committee
representative months yes that is
correct thank
you and this year we are in the process
of conducting an Actuarial
audit and we this is
considered to be a best practice as
recommended by the government Finance
Officers
Association and an Actuarial audit
involves having another Actuarial firm
come in and
recalculating and reassessing all of the
assumptions that our regular actuary
makes to ensure that our our liabilities
are stated correctly and all of our
assumptions are correct so we will be
hiring that firm soon and expect to have
August page 27 as mentioned on the prior
page our employer contributions are
comprised of three components the first
is normal cost and that is the actual
cost of the pension benefits as a
percent of the active
employees
wages there's the amortization of the
unfunded liability and as you'll see on
the next page that is the single lares
component of the employer contribution
cost our unfunded liability was 5.6
24 and then the third component is the
medical subsidy which I as I noted
earlier is a closed group and it's
rate page 28 the chart on this page
shows you what percent that each of the
three components are in the total
employer contribution as you can see the
overwhelming majority of the employer
contribution goes towards amortising the
unfunded
liability and on the bottom of the page
is the percent of the normal cost that
is paid by the different member
groups page 209 let me ask a question
here why is the teacher um unfunded
liability such a higher number is that
because more teachers collect their
pension and more in the other groups do
not do not don't get vested and that
um I will have to um get back to get
page 29 um this chart compares the
employer rates for fiscal years 24
through 25 as well as the bium of fiscal
year
2627 because of strong investment
performance in recent years we were able
once again to reduce the employer
bium next page page 30
as discussed earlier nhrs has a board as
well as an independent investment
committee both groups are fiduciaries
and are responsible for oversight of
different areas the Board of Trustees
approves the investment policy including
asset allocation for our Investment
Portfolio and hires our investment
consultant in contrast the independent
investment
committee um began its work in 2009
after was created by the legislature
prior to the that the Retirement Board
made all of the investment decisions so
the iic recommends investment policy to
the board it also oversees the
administration of the investment program
and ensures that the board's policies
are being
followed the iic also hires investment
service providers such as our custodian
where our portfolio lies as well as the
investment manager and that every year
they prepare a comprehensive annual
investment report which gets approved by
the board and sent to the legislature
and now I will turn things over to Chief
investment officer LC good morning uh on
slide 31 um it might be a little bit
tough to read but the intuition behind
the slide is to demonstrate that the
portfolio is well Diversified and we
have investments in equities bonds and
in private markets uh we regularly
review the investment team regularly
reviews uh the investment managers that
we invest with um the ask allocation
they ask the classes that we are are in
and that and we take a long-term Horizon
towards looking at the portfolio which
is to ensure that that we are
guaranteeing or or ensuring that we we
have the retirement outcomes for our
beneficiaries and
members uh and what you see in in the
pie chart on the left is Target ass
allocation in the actual as of 6:30 I
apologize for the small print as I get
older I find that you have to have them
on a full sheet of paper so uh but from
a cost perspective um we are being more
very
efficient on slide 32 uh details our
investment performance let me ask here
what what is the difference between
Target and actual I mean you're making
Investments all the time couldn't you be
at
whatever asset allocation you want it to
be right not when it comes to the
private markets um that is uh it's
difficult because those those
Investments are 10 years plus potential
extensions and so it may take a long
time for us to get to that Target for
those Investments and the other thing uh
uh um uh chair McGuire is that those
Investments um we want to be able to
diversify how much we putting out every
year so we want to be disciplined about
that so it's not you can't get to you
can get to Target quickly but all often
times it it might cause Market impact
and you can't deploy the capital fast
enough and it'll be a problem so we want
to be disciplined about how we allocate
the the capital but private markets
would be difficult to get to um very
quickly thank you representative MTS
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question um I'm I'm not going to even
pretend that I understand what Bitcoin
is but I know it's a very uh you know
it's it's in the news a lot um does the
fund hold any
Bitcoin no uh represent months we do not
hold Bitcoin um at all so it's uh have
my personal views on that um but it's uh
something that we do we don't engage in
Investments slide 32 uh will outline the
investment returns for the 135 10 and 25
year periods um these are net returns
net a fees and one thing that you'll
notice uh in in the in what Jen what our
executive director has discussed is
really an increased focus and on
transparency and um and best practices
and so taking a long-term approach
disclosing our net returns is all
something that's very very important for
us and uh on the absolute basis those
are strong investment performance for
sorry just have to ask this question um
you know the um given that the 25-year
return is
6.3%
um wouldn't that suggest that the long
that the discount rate should be closer
to 6.3 as opposed to
6.75 um which would have an impact on
the liability uh uh Mi Mr chair members
of the committee representative Mons the
assumed rate of return is a forward
looking number it is not that the past
does inform it but the way we calculate
the assumed rate of return is our
actuary
plls over a dozen investment managers
investment consultancies to see what
they expect the different how the
different asset classes will perform
over the next 10 to 20
years and then they do statistical
analysis and come up with an expected
rate of return for each asset class and
then they look at our actual asset
allocation what percent is in public um
us equities what percent is in foreign
stocks what percent is in real estate
and then does a weighted average and
that's how they come up with a
6.75% so if we let's say they were to
come up with a number
20% um they would go well well that's
what we expect for the future but how
does that comport with what's happened
in the past and then we'd say no 20%
really doesn't make sense we so that
it's so it's it's a forward-looking not
a not a backward looking
number the numbers are very close so
it's not that significant right and what
you also have to remember about the 25e
return is it includes 20012
2002 but if you were to exclude 25 years
6.75% did you want to add anything I no
I I can touch on on that in a couple
slides that can help outline that
outline us um okay on slide
33 um you'll see the time weighted um
Sor representative W thank you I have
been monitoring this over the 30 years
I've been in the legislature I know I
can't blame a lot of this on you because
how long you've been here two two almost
two and a half years three and a half
years but the volatility always bothered
me I having studied some of this years
ago and having my own Ira that I've been
watching for years is it's unacceptable
to have this amount of volatility and my
experience has been been in the years
when it was down to around 1% when you
picked up the report and read it you try
to see what the annual return wasn't it
was always we assume 6.75 they wouldn't
admit the 1% they wouldn't admit the
minus 4% you would really have to dig to
find those figures the volatility I hope
you can get it rid of it I mean some of
it may be the portfolio you chose but
you know it it's so in 25 years 6 three
doesn't seem like that great a return
and the three years 3.4 I mean you had
the
129.4 that might have been before you
got there I don't know but I don't know
what happened that time that they got
that bigger return maybe they sold a lot
of stuff but this this is not what we
can put a lot of faith in when we have
five billion in the hole and that was
when we started try to fix it in 2011 we
would like billion in the whole and it's
just gotten worse so we've got to see
some better returns and we got to see
some
consistency um what whatever you're
doing to to arrange this whoever you
hired to do this I would not hire this
is or whoever's on the committee you
need more expertise this is this is
unusual when I see endowments making 20%
UNC consistent basis from colleges what
are they doing they've got billions of
dollars like this but they don't have
this this volatility and and this quite
frequent very low returns it's it's
risky and that's why we have to keep
making up the difference because of what
happened here and I remember one
particular person I'm glad we got rid of
him he was putting some undue influence
on on what happened with this with this
and so that's that's the cause of some
of this and why we've made changes and
the the legislature looks looks at this
very carefully because costs us a lot of
money billions of dollars in the hole
where can we make it up if not in
investment returns I'm I'm going to try
to answer this a little bit but
basically if you want a a um consistent
return you go to an insurance company
and they'll give you 4% or something
like that right and they'll they'll
guarantee it forever right
gu% years all right there you go but but
the point is
risk equals um equal you know more risk
you tend to get more return right so
when you have more risk you got more
volatility
so L
return not necessarily
yeah I'll take a different view on this
and to provide a little bit more light
on on this and what I tend to look at is
the is the pattern of the bars and so
the bars you want to see are
consistently above the line which means
posit positive returns and one of the
things that we're looking at is really
addressing the risk adjusted return and
so taking you and there's no way to
limate if I if we could eliminate
volatility that would be fantastic but
as as as chair has stated you're going
to be looking at a very low return and
and that those two go hand in hand and
but what you see here is there's a
consistent return above the line and
we're looking for a just consistency
overall and to point out some of the
items that you already mentioned
represented wman is is 12 2012 this was
a debt sealing uh debate where s por has
downgraded the US treasury debt and so
that was a significant amount of uh
volatility um in 2014 2015 those are low
yield environments in the market so
there was negative rates uh in for
German and swiss deposits and that was
what was going on back then along with
weak commodity prices and so that gives
you a dynamic of what's happened and if
you're going go for that Global
financial crisis was very traumatic
covid was very traumatic and so this
Spike that you see in 2021 was the
Snapback after covid and markets uh have
uh rebounded strongly with that um so we
didn't crystallize any losses uh we
maintained our investments and and
that's why you take a long-term view so
I would I would I would argue that these
are are very consistent strong returns
and we want to you know continue to have
returns above the line positive returns
over time that compound and ultimately
allow us to achieve our retirement
interesting stud that's going to be done
compar you with other
consistently all right representative
cell thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking the question so I see on your
target you targeted for 40% inequities
between non us and domestic that your
target was 40% so your actual is 52%
that's probably what's leading to the
volatility because there's a lot a lot
of stocks a lot of equities are you
trying to right now divest of some of
the equities while everything is high
and get closer to your
target uh thank you for the question
represent camell yes that's absolutely
what we're trying to do for the new as
allocation is to rebalance from equities
and bringing that down and and uh Del
and allocating that into the fiber
markets in particular infrastructure and
that's one of the areas that's an
opportunity for us in the portfolio that
we don't have as much infrastructure in
the portfolio as you know uh um
inflation is higher than normal uh and
we believe that that should benefit the
portfolio and over the long term because
those are consistent returns that are
debt-like but uh have a sensitivity to
to
CPI and we're talking about traditional
infrastructure core infrastructure uh
not opportunistic not building new
buildings and I think that's really part
of the risk mitigation so ultimately
when you reduce equities down you're
going to be reducing the risk profile
but you can't do that in a way that
compromises our ability to get the six
and 3/4 return which actual rate of
return to Target thank you did I see a
question over here no we're all set all
on slide
34 as representative wer had asked uh
about is performance relative to our
peers and so we look at this on slide 34
our consultant Kalen uh does a look back
relative to uh public plans that are
greater than 1 billion in assets uh that
the footnote at the bottom uh will tell
you that it's 138 public plant with over
two trillion in assets under management
and over the last 15 years um we've
decisions that the IC has made out
perform 84% of our peers and so that's
relative to other firms that other plans
that are similar to us they may have
different asset allocations uh and we
may not know what their cost structure
is but from from an a return perspective
we are outperforming them and we expect
perpetuity representative
Griffin uh thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question can we get a list
peers yes we can get we actually can get
a list of that um it's a um it's
provided by Kalen our investment
consultant and so we would would want to
get what those are yeah we kind of like
to see an actual list if that's possible
welcome uh slide 35 as our executive
director uh and uh Chief Financial
Officer I've already talked to you about
some of the initiatives since I've
joined is really meant
to ensure that we have a secure and um
retirement outcomes that are for our
beneficiaries that that they expect and
so we've proposed um changing our law
our ass allocation this is that we want
to reduce equities and allocate more to
private credit and infrastructure
believe that'll be a good long-term goal
for the plan that diversification should
benefit and reduce the volatility that
uh that we are exposed to by being by
investing in the capital markets uh
fiveyear strategic plan for an
investment office that it's three
components to that one is is ultimately
we want to reduce costs and reduce costs
um by not Outsourcing as much of the
decision-making or the the the services
that we we engage in so we want to
recruit and retain our investment Talent
today uh New Hampshire is a great place
to come and work nhrs is a is a great
organization uh we also want to invest
in systems and so those systems will
allow us to be able to oversee the
portfolio Monitor and and recommend
actions to the committee uh and also um
disclose more information to the members
and beneficiaries so that's the third
piece and we're going to continue to
adopt transparent reporting across the
the private markets on our website we've
also disclosed all the managers that
we've invested in in the asset classes
so that they're relatively accessible uh
and we're going to continue to do more
members uh the last slide which I
discussed and before I turn over to
backer to our executive director is this
chart shows you the uh assumed rate of
return a national average of assume rate
of return uh relative to nhrs and so so
this is a little bit of the forward
expectations that we were talking about
before at 20 20 20 years ago they made
the estimate that returns will be 8% and
20 when you get to today it's not that
and so return expectations have been
coming down quite a bit and that's why
that that line has been coming down um
and also we may also see that in some CM
Capital Market assumptions you're
expecting that to go up because you've
gotten to a point where Market's been
depressed so much but in the 25e period
um we expect that we're going to be able
to achieve six and 34s and and I think
that's really the forward estimate that
we're looking at that our executive
director talked
about and so um we believe that's
prudent um we believe we'll be able to
achieve that and um and more because we
want to continue to to to provide those
the strong investment returns for our
with that I will yal back to executive
director thank you Mr leac page 37 is a
brief recap of 2024 there were 14 bills
introduced that would impact nhrs three
of them were enacted into law one was a
temporary supplemental allowance for
certain retirees and beneficiaries
another one had to do with um um
group two members who had accidental
disability who had suffered um violent
acts that caused their disability and
then also a revision for the group two
multiplier for certain of the tier B
members since 2007 there's been more
statute page
38 this slide summarizes NH rs's role
Visa the legisl Year we're here to
provide data and objective analysis we
provide you with fiscal note worksheets
Bill briefs testimonies such as today
and information
materials page 39 in summary as we've
gone through the presentation this
morning we've shown that nhrs provides a
modest pension amount most of the money
stays in state and supports local
economies we have a plan that's in place
to pay down our unfunded liability and
manage future volatility we've got more
on this in the next couple of slides the
board has taken responsible steps to
ensure proper plan funding as reflected
in the decisions to reduce the assumed
rate of return over the past 10 years
and the Improvement in nhs's funded
ratio relative to the nasra average
despite the impact of the reductions in
the annual rate of return so this slide
on page 40 shows how we're doing on our
path to 100% funding the path is rarely
smooth but we are definitely on the
right Road and we continue to make
progress we with our June 30 2024
valuation we are now at
68.6%
funded the next slide page 41 shows how
we expect that unfunded liability be to
be paid down s of June June 30th it was
5.6 billion and you can see we are
definitely on the path for it to be
almost completely extinguished in
2039 one of the changes that the 2017
denial commission recommended was that
any additions to the unfunded
liability starting in
2017 should be amortised over 20year
close periods whereas the original
you know majority part of that unfunded
liability is being advertised over 30
years new additions to the unfunded
liability since 2017 should be
advertised over a shorter period 20
years so the green line on this reflects
the what the unfunded liability is going
to be at different times in the
future the individual bars are comprised
of the initial pre-june 30 2017 unfunded
liability and teal and then the other
gains and losses that are being
amortised over 20 year Clos periods with
different colors for each of the
two-year periods as you can see some of
these periods have gained such as 2021
and the 23 experience study which
reduced the overall unfunded
liability Mr
chair thank you um given that on on
slide in slide 40 I mean it looks like
um the national average for funding is
about
76% is it is it even realistic to assume
that you can get to
100%
funding um or is it advisable to be at
100% um Mr chair members of the
committee Mr Ms as a fiduciary of
retirement system I would say that the
most responsible thing for a retirement
system to be is 100% funded you'll hear
the 80% number out there a lot that all
you have to do is be 80% funded but
anytime you're less than 100% funded you
are at Great risk of what might happen
in the
marketplace and so that's why we aim for
the 100% And I would not suggest aiming
for anything less because we want to
have $1 in the portfolio for every
dollar of benefits we're going to have
out and I and I understand what you're
saying um is there a cost to to to that
that additional 20% you know you
mentioned 80% is there a cost that
that um you know I guess Society
encouraged by trying to get from that
80% to
100% um Mr chair members of the
committee representative
months yes there is a cost but I would
argue that there's a greater cost by not
getting to the 100% because you're at
greater risk so that if there's a 2001
Tech bubble or there's another pandemic
you are at Great risk of having the
portfolio be further devalued and then
needing to have even higher employer
contributions because once we get to the
100% funding rate
then we the employer contribution rates
will be able to go down dramatically as
you saw on the slide in the
20s the unfunded
liability um is
responsible paying down that unfunded
liability is responsible for the
overwhelming majority page 28 the
overwhelming majority of the employer
contributions
rates and so if there's no unfunded
liability the employer contribution rate
will be able to go down dramatically
because at that point um there's just
the the normal cost of the benefit as
well as the medical subsidy there are
different triggers that are already in
statute as to how
the balance of the normal cost will be
the contributions for that will will
change once we get to 100% funding but
the employers will see a
significant overall decrease in what
they're paying so I'm going to answer it
this way for the next 15 or 16 years
every um government employee in the
state state Municipal Etc is costing us
10% more than they would be otherwise if
we were fully funded right so to get us
from where we are now 2third funded to
fully funded we're paying 10% more for
every employee effectively maybe a
little more than close to 11% and so you
know it's worth getting there because
now you could have 10% less property tax
you could have 10% higher pay you could
have whatever right but it's a cost
ahead thank you
page 42 um New Hampshire is not the only
state that's been working on reducing
its unfunded liability our neighbor to
the North and East Maine began their
efforts in 1997 whereas we really got
into it um in around 2009 and it's a
very good comparison for how our plans
are doing as they our plans are very
similar we're similar in size in terms
of actives and retirees similar average
pen mention and we also both have
similar um constitutional
Provisions so they are now at
and they are now at
86% they started at 51% back in
1996 and we are now at 68.6 so they're
about 10 years ahead of us and we're
going to keep making good
progress page
43 um as I've stated earlier and H has
constitutional and statutory Foundation
to ensure that we're on the path
to
sustainability and this is a marathon
it's not a Sprint and there are no
shortcuts and I'm very proud of the
progress that has been made and I am
determined to stay the course and that
concludes our prepared remarks we'd be
happy to try to respond to any questions
you may
have representative rung thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
just simple question how many employees
do you have and um I guess it goes to Mr
L's comments regarding the fiveyear
Strategic plan about attracting and
retaining investment Talent um how does
the profile of your employees work like
do you have any vacancies in that area
um can you comment on your your uh
attraction of new candidates and
retention um yes um Mr chair members of
the committee representative rang we
currently have 78
employees and what CIO LEC was talking
about is that with the new investment
strategic plan we will be looking to
hire different employees for the
investment division
we right now overall as an agency have a
very low vacancy
rate um our employees similar to State
Employees you know participate in a NH
HRS we have the same state health
insurance
and we
have had the same challenges that other
New Hampshire's employers have had in
attracting people because there's a very
low unemployment rate in New Hampshire
right now
but we I would say that we have been
able to fill all of the vacancies that
we have we are the ones that we do have
we're actively recruiting for thank you
another question okay and then on um
subsidy yes I can explain part of it and
I think Marie may be able um Mar Mullen
our CFO will maybe be able to explain
the rest of it so this is a we do not
provide provide health insurance what we
provide is a payment to certain former
public employees who are eligible for
this
subsidy and so they get that amount on a
monthly basis so not all public
employees are entitled to it it's as I
said earlier it's a finite group of
people who are either receiving it now
or who are current active employees e
but there are if and they all had to be
working in the year 2000 so it's a very
small group of people who are entitled
to this amount so followup so it's a
it's a finite group of people who are
working in 2000 for the state or is it
just in I would assume anybody who
we'll have to get back to details my
understanding is it's a it's an a
benefit that used to exist decades ago
right and it ended around 2000 and so
it's grandfathered in sort of for those
who were retired at that time right but
for on new new people who retire they
don't get this particular benefit and it
and it's something like paying the
co-pay the the extra payments you have
to pay to
Medicare right is what it was covered
what it used to cover sort of okay so I
think that that's my understanding but
it but it's
a from surpluses whatever but but it's
it's a benefit that that is no hasn't
been offered for decades right and and
so it's we're paying the tail sort of
just like the tale of school building
Aid and things like that so thank you
other
questions thank you very much for coming
actually let me ask just one question
based on this employee count and that
sort of stuff we don't um authorize your
employees right that's your board that
that decides that sort of thing it's not
like our employees where we keep track
of how many and all that kind of thing
that that's corre corrected the the
board is responsible for approving a
budget that's appropriate for the we
system right but the kind of things we
do is change the features and and
specifics of the plan so for example if
we want it to go from 6.75% to 6 and a
half% like Maine does we can do that by
law correct well right now it's the
board that's responsible for setting the
Actuarial rate of return um there are
some states that do set the Actuarial
rate of return but that's an experiment
that I would argue has not worked out
well for the states who do that and when
and when the state did that for NH HRS
it also did not work out well because it
was set at 99.5% which even at the end
of the 90s was a bit on the high I
thought that number is still in an RSA
somewhere no okay no all right well
there you go all right thank you very
much thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thank
yes
e
all right so uh let's uh get started and
welcome commissioner
Scott good afternoon and uh I'll put in
the middle for now and uh yeah again for
introductions I'm Bob Scott with the
Department of Environmental Services
thank you for having us here and uh for
those who would like we'll we'll
hopefully all of you uh we'll tell you a
little bit about our programs and and
and uh what we have for budget so far
but first I'd like to do some
introductions uh many of you know Susan
Carlson uh she's our chief operating
officer uh longtime state employee
brings a lot of great great um
experience for the agency uh behind me
is Adam kpo I think he's behind me
yes uh he's our assistant commissioner
and some of you may know him from his
past past Works uh we have in in order
uh what I'll do is I'll stay here and
we'll we as the discussion progresses to
different divisions we'll have the
division uh heads come up um with one
exception so Kathy beam is stepping in
in for Craig Wright uh with the air
division since Craig's unavailable today
but you'll also see Mike whimet and
Randy peler so who I believe is the
longest serving state employee in the so
um yeah you have a complicated um um
department and uh we have an hour so I'd
like to Let's Zoom through and and spend
most time on any page that has numbers
on it certainly so I will try I'll start
the zoom then so uh on uh looking at
slide number two is our or chart uh it's
kind of just as I outlined it so we have
effectively the commissioner's office is
a is a division within effectively
within the agency uh and they handle uh
probably the the least expected part of
that would be the G the state Geological
Survey and the state geologist so that's
that's how within the the agenc
uh but we have our legal unit Human
Resources accounting all the the normal
administrative functions and also uh we
we have a planning unit that tries to
guide us and move us ahead on a lot of
data database and uh e- permitting
development that that we have going on
uh the waste management division that
you'll hear uh from director whimet uh
again just we manage hadous waste Solid
Waste landfills you may have heard of
this uh recently um super F funds Brown
Fields uh storage tanks uh contamination
issues like pasas uh the Water Division
is our largest division by far uh that
is dams our our permitting and land
resource management side of of things uh
Watershed we we work with lakes and
River issues Wastewater uh issues that's
a a little bit of an outlier because you
think people think Wastewater so they
call Mic up uh with the waste management
division Wastewater is a function of the
Water Division uh drinking drinking
water is a continuous issue and we also
own and operate the we're the only
agency in the state like us that owns
and operates a Wastewater Tuma facility
so we have the Waki River Basin uh that
feeds 10 communities around that so it
is awkward I will say that we are the
regulator and the regulated on that
issue so but so be it uh the Air
Resource division again Kathy will talk
and that's really uh working with
anything that any major source of air
pollution in the State uh and also added
in that group is our health
environmental health unit so we look
that unit helps the whole whole
department and for instance drinking
water standards evaluating the science
and helping to create those in and
working with us on those standards as as
an example of the work they do so I
won't hopefully you understand our
mission and and and the the strong Nexis
between a clean environment and uh and
our a healthy economy uh so I I kind of
already listed our core functions so I
won't uh go over that yet again we have
a lot of different funding sources and
as as the chair mentioned we have a
fairly complex number of programs and
all the things we're doing so I think
based on that I I just will point one
thing out and representative lean of
course is here is one issue we really
want highlighted this year is the the
issue of funding for state-owned dams we
have 276 state owned dams we get a
capital budget appropriation every year
looking historically over the past
decades uh you know it's great that we
get capital budget money and every uh
year we do every bium we do get some but
on the current schedule we get to rehab
a dam uh once every 100 years and that's
not really sustainable for the state so
we want to have a discussion about that
certainly this year and and the
representative leechman is kind enough
to have a a bill to start that
discussion so week we have a he yeah so
we will be
there so with that I'm going to hand
over to talk a little bit about our our
budget and uh some of the financing
issues with uh Sue Carlson our chief
operating
officer good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee um on the next
slide I gave you um four bullets that
just highlight the agency phase
efficiency budget that we submitted um
for 26 um 27 is it's also close a number
to that our overall efficienc budget for
the Department was $340
million um we were given a general fund
goal of 29.5 million for both years we
met those goal
numbers um our efficiency budget for 26
actually um signals a 12% decrease from
25 primarily in our loans and
reimbursement
categories um and in 27 we decreased
that by additional four 4% another 14
million again um primarily in loans um
and reimbursements if you flip to the
next Slide the next few slides are pie
charts and what I have done is
essentially broken out our sources of
funds and our uses are funds so in FY 26
um you can see our our srf program and
for those who are unfamiliar with this
we have a state revolving Loan program
for Wastewater and drinking water that
program is a combination of what we call
repayment funds and federal funds that
is this th that srf program is our
single biggest program in Anar agency um
and it's made up primarily uh of federal
funds and repayment funds and it
accounts for 43% of our operating
budget the all the other federal funds
across all the other divisions are at
$57 million and that's approximately
another
177% of our um our operating
budget um our fees are I've broken out
the drinking water groundwater trust
program because that is our biggest
single fee program that one is at 31.2
or 9% of our operating budget all other
of our fee programs are $77 million um
and that's approximately 40 different
fee programs and they accounts for
23% our general funds at 29.5 only
represent 8% % of our operating
budget so as you can see we don't even
though it seems to be a big number it's
a very small part of our overall
operating
budget as far as General Uses of our of
our
budget 69% of our entire budget goes out
in the form of Grants reimbursements
loans and rebates um so the rest of the
remaining budget account is accounted
for in salary and benefits which is
23% operating expenses which is um
current expense telecommunications
equipment purchases those type is 15.7
or 5% of our budget contracts account
for approximately 12% loans across our
five loan
programs is 137 million or 40% of our
operating budget grants represents
another 12 % reimbursements are $18
million or another 5% and then inter
agency transfers these are the payments
we make to administrative services for
building rent
doit um Department of Justice um that
was makes up all of this and that's 8.3
or 3% of our operating
budget on the next slide what I did was
take that operating budget and break it
out by divisions so that you can see as
Bob has said our water division is our
single biggest Division and it accounts
for um over 50% of our entire budget um
in the budget because the state
revolving Loan program is its own
company it is broken out in the budget
in two the Water Division shows up in
two separate areas so in order to
provide you some consistency with how
the budget is set up I broke these two
out on these pie charts so the Water
Division other than srf operates at
about $65 million the srf program
accounts for 43% of our budget air
accounts for just 4% of robery and
budget waste management is our second
largest division and at $107 million
accounts for 32% of our budget and then
the Commissioner's Office comes in at
the bottom at 7.9 million
I've then taken M Carlson let me let me
ask a question um and this might be an
LBA question so I have a piece of paper
here that says your fiscal year 25
adjusted authorized um General funds was
18 and
A6 but you're saying it's more like
30 that is because the single biggest
general fund program we have which is
the state aid grant program program was
not included in
hb1 um it was funded out of hb2 and it
came to us as an FY 23 appropriation for
$ 29.7 million so it doesn't show up in
the adjusted authorized for 25 gotcha
much um the final slide I have to
present to you is a breakdown Again by
division which gives you the breakdown
of each division how it is by funding so
the air division as you can see has a
very small oh the blue is the blue is
General funds the green is federal funds
and the brown is other funds as you can
see the air division because it's a
small division at only 13 million has a
small piece of General funds a slightly
larger piece of federal funds and it's
used and over 50% of its funding is in
fees the commissioner's office because
of the nature of it is primarily again
is even smaller and most of our funding
is General funds with a little bit of
fee and a little bit of federal the
waste management division has a small um
component of General funds um it's
primarily funded with fee programs this
is the oil fund hazardous waste fund um
oil Pollution Control fund they are
primarily fee count the Water Division
other than srf has the
most equalized funding it is a fairly
large General funds um offset by a
little larger federal funds and even a
little more fee account now the SAG
grant for the most part is what sits in
the air excuse me sits in the Water
Division that's where our biggest um
general fund program is the um water srf
has no General
funds and it is primarily Federal and
repayment
funds
okay thank you Mr Mr chair I'm I'm one
of the newbies on this committee so bear
with me
um can you explain this srf a little bit
better a not better but you know a
little more detail I'm struggling with
what it is and how it works and the
state revolving Loan program is actually
two programs it is Wastewater and
drinking water the Wastewater srf
Federal program was started by EPA back
in the mid
80s and essentially the federal
government gives us a grant that we
match with 20% State funds to make
loans to uh low market rate loans to
municipalities to um reconstruct or
clarify so this is a congressional
appropriation it's administered through
EPA yeah um when the loan is repaid that
goes into a repayment fund and from that
repayment fund we then in turn make more
additional
loans the drink you want yes I yeah
representative evil go ahead so when you
said in the beginning that you're
reducing your budget through loans and
reimbursements
maybe you're going to get to this but is
it through the srf or what's the um in a
combination of srf and
past um I didn't want to get into this
today I had a feeling I was jumping the
gun maybe I have when we come back to
you I will have this in much more detail
for you um but the drinking water srf
program again is you know it comes from
EPA it's an 8020 program um and it was
started in the
mid90s and it is for loans and grants um
to um water drinking water systems um
both public and and small private um so
what happens is these programs have been
going on for quite a while um and we
have um staff that um support this
program and not only do they support the
Loan program but they support all their
um Federal requirements um to ensure
compliance with um for the rebuilding of
these
programs so if I could could add so the
numbers you see for the state revolving
Loan Fund
are are augmented by the infrastructure
Bill the the ija the bill money uh so
there there for the next couple years
and then it'll go back to more normal uh
they've been augmented by that but
bottom line is these are passrs to to
community water systems or Wastewater
systems did did I hear correctly that
that buried in the waste um numbers is
also and and a a revolving
fund the waste management division has
one small loan program which is the
brownfields Loan
program that is at less than a million
dollars a year
and it's oh and then the past LF which I
um and the drinking water let me back up
that's
fun let me back up there are five loan
programs there is the Clean Water srf
the drinking water srf then in the waste
management division we have the drinking
water groundwater trust fund which also
operates loans we have the past response
fund which also does loans and then we
have the brown Fields Program which I
often forget about because it's less
than a million dollars a
year they operate the same way as the as
you describe s yes they are not they
don't have quite the same Federal const
restrictions on
them that the srf does so you said that
we have to put in 20% matching funds but
there's no blue line on on this thing so
somehow the other stuff counts is that
it no no the state matches the srf
budget thank
you so before you bring the next group
up uh I I know the committee had
questions that that were sent to us
those are at the those are answered in
slides at the End by the way for those
guess representative evil so is Sag is
that what we call buo
box
yes Sor um and and actually the SAG
program is made up of three components
there is the Wastewater system component
which is the largest most active
component there is landfill closures
which uh we are not we have not offered
any new grants and years and will be
ending in
2033 and then there's the public water
interconnection sag program which is
also what we consider to be a closed
program program there's no new grants
being offered under those that funding
will end in
2052 okay and these are for the
committee's edification the SAG program
is an after Thea grant program where um
we pay essentially 20% of The Debt
Service payments on any bonded debt they
have that qualifies under these programs
and everything
um under these programs of course is
subject to funding and that's a state
only program there's no federal
right and then I suppose you are holding
your breath to see what happens with the
federal fund halt been well it's been
it oh okay all right I did not know that
well you heard it here first
but but it's likely to there will be
some cutbacks I I would guess but anyway
we'll
see yes representative Le uh thank you
Mr chairman so Susan you kind of went
very quickly over the 12% decrease uh 47
million for the loans and
reimbursements what are you looking to
reduce is that going into those delayed
and deferreds or no essentially we we
received a great deal of bill money in
24 and
25 um and so we had up those budgets
considerably um because we received so
much funding um and what we did was we
took a hard look at what those amounts
were and we right sized the budget
downward for 26 and 27 for those so
followup Mr chairman so you're not
cutting back any of the existing
commitments that this Dees has made to
communities at all if we've made the
commitment we that commitment okay thank
you thanks Mr
chairman oh sorry thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my
question um if we look like the EPA I
think it's section 319 grants um there's
a match involved I think with
municipalities or groups that are
accessing those funds how do we capture
their match on this
if a third party is matching it does not
show in our budget what they do is they
provide documentation to us that they
have expended the matching funds and we
record that um in our in our grant
management system so that we can
document that for reporting to the
you um that ended my first presentation
and I will be turning it over to um the
air Division and and Cathy to discuss
does good afternoon
chair so in keeping with the chair's
request to be uh brief and given that we
are 4% of the budget I will be very
brief in the 4% of the time yes um I
just want to do a brief overview of the
Air Resource Division and our areas of
responsibility if you look at slide 12
we are um the director Craig Wright and
the assistant director Mike Fitzgerald I
work for them in the director's office
where we do Regional and National um
work as well as Ru making budgets and
and the like we have three bureaus in
the era division permitting and
environmental health compliance Bureau
and Technical Services Bureau on the
next slide you could see that the
permanent and environmental health
bureau's
responsibilities are to issue state and
federal air permits uh so we have
delegation of the federal Title 5 uh
Clean Air Act permitting program which
allows us to work directly with the
Hampshire sources on their compliance
status and their permitting um as
opposed to having EPA uh write their
permits and then we also work with them
to ensure their compliance status with
the rules and regulations and then the
other half of that Bureau also deals
with uh the environmental health program
which helps across air water and waste
division standards evalu valuating
Health impacts related to contaminants
and also helps with our air toxics
program required under our
statutes the next slide talks a little
bit about the permitting uh work that we
do here in New Hampshire we have roughly
800 permitted sources in the state and
about half of them are covered under
what's called a general State permit
which covers emergency generators and it
basically puts all the requirements of
how to operate larger emergency
generators into one permit that they're
they can re register for
um also as the granite state we have a
lot of Rock crushing operations so we
have a permit by notification program
for those and then as I said we
facilitate the federal permit program
the title five sources we have 28 in the
state so that covers landfills power
plants um incinerators that sort of
situation and then the remainder are
construction permits and state permits
required under our state statutes and
and permitting rules uh the next slide
talks about our compliance Bureau so
they have a couple of different
responsibilities to ensure compliance
with the Clean Air Act One Is to uh
observe stack tests that occur at
facilities through throughout the state
we roughly do between 40 and 50 emission
compliance tests a year uh we we go to
the facility and observe that they're
compliance with procedures um the
sources themselves conduct the stack
test through their consultants and then
we verified 24 continuous emission
monitors that exist in the state to make
sure they're operating in accordance
with with state and federal
requirements in addition on the next
slide our compliance Bureau conducts
inspections of the stationary sources we
do about 60 to 80 inspections a year we
do the title five sources every two
years and then the remainder are the
state sources we also do compliance
assistance and we respond to
approximately 70 to 80 air permit air
quality complaints per year and in 2023
we successfully settled 116 Enforcement
cases our elves without any federal over
filing from EPA so that was a
success in addition the compliance
Bureau has a section that deals with
aestus management um we have the ability
to uh certify and license um people who
do remediation of uh asbest as well as
notifications of demolition work that's
being done we also inspect schools under
the ahara program and one would think
that ASB bestus would be something
that's not as prevalent as it used to be
it's actually just the opposite we've
actually gone up in the number of
inspections and certifications and
licenses over the years as more and more
people are remodeling existing
facilities or
demolishing
buildings and then the third Bureau that
I want to talk about is the technical
services Bureau uh they uh service our
entire air monitoring system which
exists across the the state from the Sea
Coast all the way up to the White
Mountains and across the central part
and and all the way over to Keen uh the
monitoring Network is used to um monitor
for certain pollutants that EPA has
requirements on they're called National
ambient air quality standards for things
like ozone particulate sulfur dioxide um
we use this monitoring Network to show
our compliance status with those
national
standards and then in addition the
technical services Bureau on the next
slide um has a mobile sources unit where
we' um administer Volkswagen and diesel
emission reduction act grants we offer
or we help with the New Hampshire Clean
Cities program and we oversee mobile
Source programs such as your onboard
diagnostics or inspection uh check
engine light and just to go a little bit
into the the Volkswagen mitigation trust
allocations uh in October of 2017 New
Hampshire was allocated 30.9 million of
the Volkswagen um settlement and
initially it was uh administered by the
op the office of strategic initiatives
but that was replaced by the department
of energy and so in August of 2021 New
Hampshire Dees became the lead agency
and you can see from the pie chart
approximately how many dollars are
corporated into Municipal vehicles state
vehicles and competitive grants we just
recently went out with an RFP for
competitive grants and I believe the
state vehicle portion has been spent
down we won't be using all of the
administrative uh portion we'll be
moving that over to competitive grants
to put that out to to bid and then the
other part of Technical Services Bureau
is that we work in conjunction with the
Department of energy here in New
Hampshire to be the technical lead on
the regional greenhouse gas Initiative
Program as well as certifying emissions
and compliance with standards under the
renewable portfolio standards and
working toward the heat pump accelerator
program under the IRA program and just
to wrap this all up with the last slide
just to show you where we are in terms
of air quality in New Hampshire um we
are an attainment for those national
standards I talked about about 90% of
the time our air quality is considered
what they call good air quality under an
air quality index that's the green bars
on that chart about 5% of the time so
95% of the time we're either in good and
moderate but as you can see there are
occasionally at each of those monitoring
sites uh a level of unhealthy for
sensitive groups so that's the orange
bar at the top um if you were to
remember the U wood smoke or the uh four
fire U issues that we had the last
couple of Summers um we didn't actually
see those impacts as much in New
Hampshire because of the weather um but
if if you had seen it down in like say
the New York area those bars would have
been in the red to purple uh range for
the air quality index so with that I
will sum it up all right representative
rung thank you Mr chair on the uh
compliance Bureau inspection slide you
mentioned that there you respond to
approximately 70 to 100 air quality
complaints per year how many sources
does that um I mean I'm sure it's not 70
or 80 sources um I'm just trying to see
if there are a few bad actors that are
the bulk of those complaints um thank
you for your question so the majority of
the complaints are actually from things
such as outdoor wood fired boilers or
wood heating hydronic heaters I guess
they're called um neighbor to neighbor
complaints on burning open burning and
that sort of thing sometimes the bestus
issues so it's not really all about the
industrial sources the stationary
sources as much as it is local uh
complaints okay thank you and one more
question sure think I'm ashamed that I I
think I should know this but on the
slide regarding the air monitoring
what's PM subset 2.5 sure so that's
particular matter less than 2.5 microns
in diameter so it's the very fine
particulate that can get down into your
lungs yeah I got it okay thank you you
sure so is your uh Bureau more or less
self-supporting with permitting fees and
fines and things like that compared to
expenses or not so I believe we're 30%
funded by um grants and
and federal programs and then the
majority of it is with fees yes okay and
you mentioned it fines so any fine that
under their statute 125 goes to the
general fund I see
right but if you sort of put a bubble
around the whole
thing there's roughly it's it's taken
care of itself right I mean that's
you so now Mike whimet will come up to
talk about the waste management division
how are we doing for time Mr
chair half hour
left good afternoon uh Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mike whimet I serve as
director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire Dees and I
understand you want to be able to focus
on specific questions so I will be
relatively brief um the waste management
division is really comprised of five
bureaus and I I think the best way to
describe it is we have a series of
programs within our bureaus that are
designed to make sure that we handle
waste and materials safely so they don't
get into the environment whether that's
hazardous waste Solid Waste or petroleum
products and then the other part of the
division is about when that when we fall
down on that when that doesn't work out
so well and those things get released to
the environment we have programs site
remediation programs that are designed
to investigate and remediate those
releases so that they don't have an
adverse impact on people's health so in
a nutshell I think that's the best way
to quickest way to describe us um so
again um as part of that uh we we have
uh there this primary responsibility
slide describes a bunch of things which
I'm going to go through in the other
slides so I won won't go through it on
this slide as far as uh assuring proper
management of petroleum products um we
operate a very robust uh oil U
remediation and compliance Bureau that
um has design requirements and and
compliance monitoring for both
underground and above ground storage
tanks we operate um a safe tank program
for um home believe or not a lot of the
releases that occur from home heating
oil tanks at residences and we have a
safe tank program that we operate that
provides reimbursement for um a small
amount of money to bring a deficient uh
home heating oil tank in a compliance so
it's less likely to have a release so we
spend a few thousand to save what on
average costs about $30,000 to the fund
if we have to rely respond to a release
um we also operate a green yards program
um auto salvage yards in the state have
had for their size they've had a
disproportionate impact on groundwater
quality as a result of poor oper ations
over the years and we worked very hard
for a number of years to operate a
program that helps them understand what
they need to do to to to manage the
fluids the automotive fluids that they
that they encounter and to try to
minimize those impacts and then um we
also uh uh operate a uh uh work on
removing non-compliant tanks we have a
number of programs to try to get those
non-compliant tanks out of the
ground uh with regard to assuring proper
management of solid and hazardous waste
our our solid waste and hazardous waste
bureaus operate both compliance
assurance and monitoring and inspection
programs for facilities in both of those
categories uh we also operate permitting
programs particularly in the solid waste
program every solid waste facility is
required to have a permit we administer
our regulation of those facilities
through a permit system we spend a lot
of time providing technical assistance
we have very robust training programs in
both of those areas is where um if
you're a solid waste operator even at
just a transfer station you're required
to get certified as a solid waste
operator and we operate a very popular
training program to make sure that even
just the guy right in the front line
dealing with your trash when you bring
it to him on the trans at the transfer
station on Saturday that he understands
um what the issues are there what needs
to be done to make sure that those
wastes are managed safely and on our
Hazard way side um a little more complex
we do uh for large larer generators of
of hazardous waste are required to have
a hazardous waste coordinator that's
certified by the department and they go
through a training program on an annual
basis to make sure and maintain that
training to make sure that they can
safely manage hazardous wastes um we
also do complaint investigations in both
of those categories and as Susan
indicated earlier we do operate a
landfill closure grant program which was
very active a few decades ago when a lot
of Municipal unlined Solid Waste
landfills were being en closed but many
of those have done their work and the
their their their bond payments are are
are winding down so that program from a
budgetary standpoint is getting smaller
and smaller each year um we do operate
um a very important emergency spill
response program we have one at least
one person on call uh 24 hours a day 7
days a week 365 days a year to assist
our um local First Responders Whenever
there is a release of hazardous waste or
hazardous materials or oil so um you
know this time of year we got a lot of
oil peder trucks going over the road and
we have weather events like I think
we're going to have today where some of
them will go off the road and create a
problem or if there's a tractor trailer
that gets into an accident on the
interstate and the saddle tanks of
diesel fuel get ruptured and spill um of
course our fire departments are our
First Responders for that but they rely
heavily on our staff to come out to the
scene help uh address the is impacts of
any releases and if necessary call in
our contractors to provide um
remediation and clean up of those of
those events um we also have a lot of
Partners in that we coordinate with the
homeland security and Emergency
Management State Police and again those
local fire departments um we also do a
lot of response planning for both Inland
and Coastal respons uh potential spills
we have um a lot of oil storage uh
capacity on the SE Coast that
potentially threatens scaa River and
Great Bay so we spend some resources to
make sure we have a response plan for
that we manage uh we have a whole
booming strategy to protect Great Bay
and we have booming strategies to
protect other other waterways on the Sea
Coast and Inland and we we we spent a
lot of time being prepared for that we
work with our partners who include you
know our main D because we share the
water with them uh the Coast Guard EPA
the Naval Shipyard um and all of our
other local state um part Partners in
that then uh with respect to
contaminated site investigation
remediation we do oversee the
investigation and Remediation of any
sites where petroleum has been released
haard waste and we also have a a federal
program where we uh administer and and
and our partners with EPA to manage 22
Federal super fund sites and also
Department of Defense sites here in the
state and I want to mention the oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
that's a very significant fund that
provides secondary insurance for owners
of underground storage tanks under
federal law if you own and operate an
underground storage tank with per
petroleum you were required to have um a
minimum of a million dollars of coverage
insurance to to address a release from
that tank and for a number of our small
gas stations and operators that is a
difficult thing to do that that
insurance in the private Market can be
difficult to get and expensive and so
many years ago when we we knew we had a
really a fleet a crisis if you will of
of of of failing tanks back in the 80s
that were creating just a a tremendous
amount of liability that nobody was
going to be prepared to deal with the
oil discharge disposal cleaner fund was
created it imposes a fee on the import
of any oil to the state and that goes
into a fund that's administered by the
oil discharge disposal or the oil fund
dispersement board which is an
independent board that is
administratively attached to Dees they
meet monthly and I'm the commissioner's
designity of that board and they
basically make decisions about and we
have a set of rules they have a set of
rules that govern uh if you bring if you
have a compliant tank you bring a tank
into compliance and you have a release
you exhaust any private insurance that
may be applicable to it but after that
you're eligible for reimbursement for
your costs of investigation and cleanup
and monitoring over time um from that
fund so that's a significant part of our
budget it's been a very important um
program in this state for many many
years and
that representative wer I remember in
the past we we built up quite a an
amount in the odd fund as you say all
oil distribution and Disposal what's it
sitting at these days I'm not sure what
the exact number is for the balance but
there is a there's kind of a a governor
on that so if um the way that the law is
set up if the balance in the fund
exceeds 5 million then the unobligated
balance exceeds 5 million then the fund
is required the fee is required to be uh
cease collecting it until the the drops
down so the way it's managed and with
the with the demands that are on it
generally you know we we don't that does
not happen we stay below that 5 million
um and actually there there will be a
bill we we've we hired an actuary to
evaluate what that looks like over 10
years the the fund sunsets every 10
years and it's sunsetting this year so
every you know we we we hired actuary to
really evaluate where we've been at
where we what we look what it looks like
we're going to get using projections
about future Imports of oil and revenues
and such and they made recommendations
to the board about how those fees should
be adjusted and there's a bill to make
those adjustments this because 5 million
doesn't sound like a lot if if we have a
spill these days that is correct we I
will tell you that we do have we
encumber a certain amount of money um I
think it's on the order of about 2
million now with contractors to be at
the ready in the event of a spill on the
Sea Coast um in the first instance if
there were a release it would be the
responsibility of the party who caused
the release to bring in a contractor but
because time is of the essence if we
didn't get full cooperation with that we
stand ready with our contractors to come
in for the first few days of that until
things can get sorted thank you you're
welcome representative Ms thank you Mr
chair thank you for U taking my question
um I'm I'm really surprised that the
number of uh DOD sites in the state
um and given that large number are those
is is has funding from the federal
government been made available to
address the on the remediation of those
sites yes the Department of Defense
sites are funded um by the government so
we get a grant that's provided by the
federal government to to address those
sites in the whether it could be the Air
Force or the Navy depending on the
particular um site but they they take
the lead in doing the work we oversee
that and if there's work that's needed
for oversight or costs associated with
oversight there is a um a Federal grant
that comes from the Department of
Defense to to cover those
costs so um this chart here shows that
the you get almost 70 million a little
more in other funds what what is that
compris so I believe that's a
combination of so the the odd the odd
fund that budget is somewhere on the
order of about 16 million I think this
year um or maybe a little more more than
that with with with operations and then
um the um uh drinking water and
groundwater trust fund represents a
significant portion of that as well 30
million yeah and then
P right so the past uh budget is about
the or the uh drinking water groundwater
trust fund budget this year is on the
order of about 30 million and then the p
budg or the other funds so all in
combination those all come to about 70
million in this year's budget so is
those fines or no no no um so the in the
case of the oil fund it's that import
fee that I just spoke about in the case
of the drinking water and groundwater
trust fund that was entirely capitalized
through the mtbe lawsuit that um that
was uh that the the state took and
actually from the settlement or from the
verdict monies that came from the
lawsuit against Exon Mobile specifically
so that was capitalized that drinking
water groundwater trust fund was
capitalized with about $280 million um
several years ago and so that the budget
now represents the annual budget that
we're the the amount you're taking from
it I got you all right thank you other
I I I think we believe that sometime
this calendar year initial dispersements
from that will happen but that is under
the terms of the settlement agreement
and it's only one settlement agreement
there's still additional ones that are
likely to come um there's a certain
there's a schedule for payout over that
so it's actually going to happen over
several years but there is expected to
be a substantial dispersement from from
year uh we we don't know the answer to
that we we I think we budgeted around 55
million we think it may well be more
than that but we we just don't that
hasn't sort of sugared off yet if you
will and we're waiting to find out what
that's going to be and just to clarify
so that settlement is for Public Water
Systems there's also legal action still
ongoing about private Wells so that that
will be years to come if whatever comes
of that um and the trust fund is already
uh authorized that money goes to the
trust fund and and they've already uh
committed that that at least the first
tranch of that will go to the
dees and it will be reimbursed to
impacted water systems that have
expended Monies to remediate p on a
proportional basis so so what we're
trying to do is the good news is we
probably got with the AG's office and
our staff we we basically I think as a
state we're getting more of this
settlement money than any other
proportionally the bad news is for the
most part you're talking pennies or
dimes on a dollar compared to what the
cost was or impact was but again our
commitment was for those who have
expended money to clean this up is going
to be proportional to that their their
fair share so to
speak we comp I
understand let's continue and then uh
lastly I'll realizing we're running
short on time here I'll finish we talked
about the trust fund my last slide is
regarding past response and now there's
we do a variety of work we dis first
discovered our first past site was the
PE Air Force Base back in 2014 so we're
more than 10 years into this uh but in
2016 we discovered two very significant
air deposition sites in Southern New
Hampshire that it really had an outsized
impact on uh private and public drinking
water resources in southern Hampshire so
we are spent a lot of time and effort um
investigating and researching that um
trying to provide at the end of the day
we really want to make sure people
aren't being exposed to these so a lot
of our work is focused on uh figuring
out where we we see p fast and drinking
water and making sure that people have
either treatment or alternate sources of
Safe Drinking Water um to that end uh we
have a past loan and grant program that
has provided $71 million to public
drinking water systems and
municipalities we operate a rebate
program for individuals so that if you
are a you know a homeowner who has a a
well impacted by P you can um get you
know a local water provider or treatment
provider to put a point of entry
treatment system on your well and you're
entitled to um if you're eligible to get
up to $5,000 reimbursement to offset the
costs of that treatment and also if
you're fortunate enough to live close to
a drinking water line um then you can
get up to $10,000 to to offset the cost
of connecting into that drinking water
public drinking water system and then we
also have a uh uh IIs firefighting foam
um takeback program that we operated to
assist our fire departments in New
Hampshire and we took back just this
past year we took back uh about 11,000
gallons of these Legacy firefighting
Foams that contain high levels of pasas
and we had entered into a contract with
a company out ofate that has treated in
that firefighting foam to destroy it so
we're really glad to get those Legacy
stocks and assists our local fire
service organizations with getting rid
of that material and I'll leave it at
that so commissioner why is p and mbte
and so on part of the waste management
Division and not the Water Division I
guess I I two two answers one the Water
Division is already quite large and
second of all again these are
contaminants right so as Mike mentioned
they have two major goals one is to
prevent releases and the other is to
work once the release happens so that's
kind of how the waste management
division gets in the the the first one's
with it sort of speak as opposed to
Natural contaminants like correct my
well has arsenic right correct so then
you have to talk to the Water Division
for I got you all right thank you other
questions representative mons yes thanks
um where where does the money for the uh
the past loan and grant program come
from that is that was from uh general
fund and bond um Appropriations that
occurred in the legislature over the
last several years okay nice
followup and then um if I heard
correctly the um the drinking water and
groundwater trust fund is used to help
with PS um
mitigation um where does the where's
where's the line between that trust fund
and the P loan and grant program sure so
it's broader than that the drinking
water groundwater trust fund was
established really um broadly to address
uh ensuring that we protect the quality
of our Drinking Water Resources in
groundwater and and also to assist
public drinking water systems with not
only addressing contamination where they
might find it and that could be pasas or
any other contaminant or naturally
current containment it could be to
address arsenic um um but also to assist
them with maintaining the quality of
their infrastructure so we've had a
number there millions of dollars that
have been um appropriate or awarded by
the drinking water and groundwater trust
fund advisory commission to eligible
Public Water Systems to you know replace
aging water lines and and and improve or
improve the quality and the and the
condition of their treatment systems so
it covers a lot of work the the it it
does do past for sure and I guess I
would say that we are um on the front
foot on all of our programs with past
almost all of our programs have provided
some kind of assistance for past we work
very close closely with the Water
Division you know they have these srf
programs that they've operated for years
so we're we're really working hard and
and I'm really proud that we're working
very efficiently with the Water Division
to as efficiently as we can administer
loans and grants whether it's from the
past response fund or from the drana
groundwater trust fund or from this srf
program or from a number of new federal
programs like the you know emerging
contaminants and uh disadvantaged
communities grant program we're working
really as we're looking at all those as
a portfolio of ways that we can help
local water systems and and we use them
we try to use them as efficiently as we
can to get them administered chairman if
I can clarify so the trust fund is a I
get is it 17 or 14 person member
commission set up by the legislature by
Statute I'm on it and they decide how to
disperse those funds the agency is the
is tasked to
administer those funds meaning the trust
fund will vote say go do this this and
then we do the do the work for
it so that brings up something we ask
most people is are you assigned to any
commissions that aren't meeting or are
unnecessary or things like that because
we're trying to clean up some of that
kind of no that for me personally again
I'm on the drinking water groundw trust
front commission I'm on the site
evaluation committee so if you'd like to
relieve me of that I would be very happy
uh but no I'm not I'm not thinking
nothing comes to mind that I'm set up by
Statute that I'm actually not probably
the site of valuation doesn't meet that
often right so uh it's spotty depends on
what what's fire chairman wer I remember
60 years ago when we brought this new
firefighting foam in it replaced this
smelly stuff that it replaced what a
wonderful thing so now what are we
replacing this with it's a great
question and it has to be said that
those Foams served a very important
Public Safety purpose because they do
work really well and they undoubtedly
save lives however um they also create a
lot of Legacy contamination so
fortunately the industry um has had a
number of years to understanding that
these pose a risk and they've been
working to develop Florine free Foams
that are still very effective and those
are are coming on the market and you
know even folks like uh actually
M Boston Regional Airport is one of the
leaders actually getting rid of their
legacy Foams and moving to non-f floring
Foams thank you you're
think yeah I can see that so last but
not
least so we we have the least time to
talk about the largest
division perfect perfect I don't think
I've ever spoke for five minutes of my
life so for the record uh chairman Randy
P here I'm the director of The Water
Division and have been in state
government my whole life pretty much
shows you how smile I am 51 years I'm on
it'll be 53 in April 53 years in
St
so if I should not off don't take it
personally now really I have the Water
Division as Bob and Susan notice is
certainly the largest division within
Dees that we have some 258 staff if you
look at the first slide it basically
shows the eight programs that we operate
and it's I would say that the water
division with its permitting programs we
issue a lot probably most of the permits
in state government that affect person's
personal lives you know and I think many
times they become very emotional and I
think we spent a lot of time and effort
educating our staff and our our goal is
to treat people like we would want to be
treated but it uh many of the permitting
process that we go through become very
emotional for a lot of people housing is
the largest investment of their life and
people get a little antsy if you will so
on the first next slide you talk about
the alteration of the terrain program in
short what that does is anytime you've
got a large development whether it be
housing whether it be commercial it
could be a Walmart or Home Depot that
disturbs more than 100,000 square ft of
area which is roughly about 2 and 1/2
acres then in fact back you have to come
in and get an alteration of terrain
permit and the reason for that
permitting why it's an important program
is because it deals with storm waterer
runoff and that is we control in their
designs what pre and post runoff is and
I will tell you that when I started
years ago we all of what we dealt with
pretty much was Water and Wastewater now
the issues of the next 10 or 15 years is
storm water clearly storm water is a big
deal it's a really important program and
I think it's only going to become more
important as representative rung you
probably know this firsthand but our
water quality in our lakes and rivers is
not getting better and a lot of that is
we must do a better job of controlling
storm water so with that being said the
next program is a subsurface systems
program in for what that is in layman's
terms anybody that's building a house or
a facility or commercial or residential
they need if they need on-site septic
system and what happens is we have a
permitting program we permit somewhere
around 6,000 applications a year for
on-site Wastewater and with that we
licensed some 400 designers we licensed
about the same installers so people have
to be certified and what has changed
over my lifetime is back when I was a
Youngster you could put in a septic
system a stone and pipe for3 or
$4,000 now the average cost of a septic
system is somewhere in the 25 to 30
range and the same issue has gone up in
the escalated cost of a well the average
well today if it's a drill Bedrock well
costs somewhere around $25 to
$30,000 so when you get involved and
you're doing site preparation for it
could be a two a a lot you bought right
out of the gate you're looking at
$60,000 without looking that's not
because of us by the way that's just
what the market is is looking at and and
materials for everything has gone up so
yes representative run uh you mentioned
you deal with 6,000 applications per
year are those all like single residence
applications do you do any like group
septic systems for like housing
developments I would say the L shares
single family residences but if you're
doing let's say you're doing a
condominium complex you've got 30 units
you may come in and have that divided up
into three different systems to service
all 30 houses so it could be multiple
approaches but the Lion Share is single
family uh Next program that I'll go over
is the Shoreland program uh for those of
you probably are aware that that 483 B
is a statute that regulates activity on
Shoreland property within 250 ft of a
lake or river and forth a of stream or
not that's a another very important
program because what that does is it
evaluates site development that it's
done properly control the amount of
vegetation removed yet again all of the
requirements of that program are to
minimize storm
water runoff so with that next is the
program and that is a program as you can
read is anytime you dredge a fill uh you
put in a dock um you do a stream
restoration as you all know the anomaly
in storm events we've had in the last
several years we've done a lot of stream
restoration work which is very costly um
and is is
the weather changes if you will we have
these extreme weather events Wetlands
program has a on call person as well
that would house the hscm if needed
along with the drinking water folks and
if people have a problem a road blows
out a cover blows out we do issue
emergency permits and then we follow up
after so what we try and do is make sure
whatever the problem is can be resolved
at least in the short term and then we
follow up later and we administer for
that program in concert with the US Army
Corp of Engineers yes so next slide you
talk about the drinking water and
groundwater program that basically is
when we look at any public Wells that
are going to serve 15 or more people
that comes through that program and we
have uh the smaller Wells and the larger
WS we have very different uh rules that
operate how they develop those wells in
the the main thrs of the well system is
we want to make sure that if we're
approving a large production well let's
say that it doesn't dewat private wells
in the area or it's it's cleaning up
it's not drawing from a water supply
Source or something very active program
um we also regulate some 2600 Public
Water Systems people submit
electronically their water samples that
they have done at a private lab that all
comes into US electronically and then
that again is electronically sent to EPA
what happens which is unique in the
drinking water program is we have what
is called Primacy so what happens is we
have committed to to basically
overseeing Federal Safe Drinking Water
Act the state also has its own statue
485 which is a Safe Drinking Water Act
but because we have Primacy it kind of
keeps EPA in Boston and we we oversee
what they would regulate it's been a
very effective program the next slide
you see is the dam Bureau chair I'm I'm
zipping along
here is the dam Bureau we have some some
276 state owned dams um and
representative Lehman is gone but he's
been working with us to figure out
funding for that program we generally
have capital budget money that comes in
as Bob mentioned earlier if we got what
we currently receive it would take us a
100 years to do all the DMS currently
there we've done on the back of the
envelope we've got what we call 64 High
Hazard dams if those would have fail it
would be loss of life
uh major public infrastructure loss we
have 64 of
those if we calculate and we roughly
calculated that if we needed to bring
all of those dams up to speed where they
should be we're talking somewhere around
million if you look at all of the
state-owned dams which we have is
276 with somewhere in the price range of
480 500 million and that's just to deal
with a state-owned dam we regulate some
2600 public dams then privately owned
dams within the system and a lot of the
state-owned dams we have dams that were
fishing game dams do any of these
generate electricity or the yeah we have
I
think last blush I think we have 11 that
generate lot they're pretty minor
producers do you get you get some income
then they pay a lease I see on the dam
to be blunt that the amount they pay is
really not the issue is if we have a
leas c they take over the the for the D
and that's having said that that is the
trend is that they are not they're
giving up their leases because they they
require Fork licensing for do 50-year
permits and most of those permits are
coming due and all the changes like fish
ladders that have come over the 50e
period are making it so that that it's
not cost effective I think uh one en
they gave up their Dam they they did the
calculation they said it would the ROI
would be 100 years you obviously that's
not
sustainable do you also look at um
removal of dams we do and that that is a
very active program where people get to
a point in time where they can no longer
afford to maintain it sometimes on the
larger dams it's as cost effective to
remove as it is to replace so that is
always evaluated the all of the water
programs get involved because of the
sediment downslip stream and so forth
and so on dams are very emotional you
know any Dam that creates an empowerment
that has generated Waterfront for
people don't want to see that damn go
away yet they've lived on it like when
soar is a good example you know we have
the Lakeport Dam in Lakeport and there's
probably billions of dollars on that
property and nobody pays a dime for that
Dam we're looking at somewhere around1
to 12 million that's needed for that dam
in the short term and representative
Lehman has has sponsored a bill and
we're trying to figure out Revenue so
that we can get at these large dams
because let's face it people that have
had waterfront property forever don't
want to lose that in the towns don't
want to lose the tax revenue so we're
not the friend person in the room when
we talk about dam removal so how much
lower would like one of baki be if we
weren't able to keep Lake Port Dam yeah
be we guess there a somewhere around 10
ft and you may hear about it if it Happ
yeah some of the smaller dams some of
the lakes that we have ows on they lose
20 feet all right representative months
but we're going to have to move along
thank you um are re are are owners of
private dams required to have any
special Insurance to uh protect the
against they pay they pay a registration
fee but we don't require they have to
have an emergency plan in place so if
something happens to that Dam they have
a strategy in place how they would
manage that but as far as the state
not so I've got a couple left chairman
but I can skip those if you prefer
yeah I kind of like to get to the last
page which with our questions if you
don't
mind come up thank you and I'm sure
we're going to see you
again in a month or whatever
you so we're looking at slide 46 for
yeah the house finance division one
question
um in the email when we were invited
here we were given some questions one of
which was what new general fund programs
have we um had in the last five years um
we identified three programs the CYO
bacteria program the PCB program and the
solid waste food diversion food waste
diversion program um all three of these
receive funding in the 2425 Bal budget
under
hb2 um in each case it was approximately
a million dollars allocated to these
three programs under cob bacteria we
have um spent over half the money um all
of it would have been gone except we
received a million dollars in arpa funds
for Soo bacteria so we moved um the
funding over to arpa which will allow us
to spend the balance of this in the
upcoming two
years um the piece BCB program um came
through as a result of a Monsanto
lawsuit settlement this state received
um approximately $25 million all of that
went into the general fund um and we
were appropriate a million dollars for
this program um currently the way the
statute is written we have to develop
administrative rules before we can issue
any grants and we're in the process of
developing those
rules um the solid waste food waste
diversion program um again came to us
through
hb2 um they also gave us a full-time
position we have um gotten the full-time
position currently filled um and that
position and the rest of the division is
developing the administrative rules to
issue that grant program right now um
the expenses incurred to date um reflect
the expenses we've incurred for the
position
so none of these would have new funds in
the coming budget or not likely ECB and
cob bacteria do not have new
funds um but the food waste diversion
program is part of the solid waste
program and that is a budgeted account
gotcha but we are tracking this million
dollars and using this primarily for the
thank
the we are asked the how many new
positions we've received over the last
um five years um I broke it down between
permanent full-time and temporary
full-time I did not include part-time
positions because part-time positions
come and go um we have received um nine
general fund positions um 37 federally
funded positions 10 other funded
positions um for a total of 56 as you
can see the majority of the federal and
other fun positions are full-time
temporary these are positions we've
asked to be created because we
have Bill funding our Ira funding um and
um to do that um we had to create the
positions because we have fiveyear
funding on those and then we are asked
if our general fund budget is
supplanting um Opera funds and we are
not doing that representative Griffin
yeah yeah thank you for taking my
question
um are any of those Federal positions
are they they all
still are they all still funded by
federal funds or have any of them been
converted to State funding no those
Federal positions are funded by federal
funds thank you Mr chair if I could
elaborate why we need those full-time
temporary positions so again as I
mentioned we have a big influx of
infrastructure funds and we had the arpa
funds and the way we administer the
those is we just don't write a check to
the community and say you said you're
going to do this water infrastructure I
hope it works out we we basically do it
on a reimbursement basis uh and some of
that is loans also so we need to be able
to and there's a lot of federal Cross
Cutters we have to do a lot of reporting
and that type of stuff so as the program
is as the as the uh project at the local
communities is designed and as built and
then commissioned we have to basically
verify that it's meeting all the
requirements so we can issue that money
to the towns to reimburse them and then
of course if it's a loan that could be
30 years 20 years that we have to
administer the loan
so I say that because you know a
snapshot would say well what's the
problem you got this extra money you
gave it to the town why do you need
staff it's because of all those
conditions that we need the staff to to
to go with that but they're temporary
because when the money runs out the
position goes away right okay all right
well thank you oh all right one quick
one from uh just comment Mr chair
regarding the Cy bacteria fund there is
a bill that um I'm the prime sponsor of
to have a new conservation license plate
that would the proceeds would go to fund
the cyano bacteria
fund I I made B once never to do a
license plate bill
but anyways thank you very much and we
will see you again and I apologize to
the U business Finance Authority for
than for coming please introduce
yourself uh thank you Mr chair for the
record I'm James key Wallace executive
director of the New Hampshire business
Finance Authority and uh no apologies
needed for uh the delay it's really I
should apologize for being unable to
attend last week I was testifying a few
Doors Down I think or maybe actually
across the street uh so thank you for
your patience um so I'm the director of
the New Hampshire BFA and I have
information related to the the questions
that were sent to me via the chair um
but I also understand that you would
just like to hear a little bit about
what who the BFA is what do we do and
and how we do it so I'm I'm happy to
jump into that if that would be helpful
okay thank you um so one thing I always
like to kind of get out of the way right
off the bat um the BFA is one of the
self-funded independent authorities in
the state I understand I think last week
you heard from uh New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority um we're very
different than than them in our scope
and our mission but uh the legal
structure of the New Hampshire BFA and
the Housing Authority are are very
similar in that none of us are actually
state employees our activ ities are
governed by Statute but uh we use no
State money we don't get any
Appropriations for the budget we're not
part of the retirement system uh
crucially the conduit debt the BFA
issues for development projects with a
few exceptions is not part of the debt
of the state so we're really separate uh
the board is appointed by the governor
and confirmed by the executive Council
um and then we have 10 voting members
and there's actually four legislative
members on our board as well two from
the house two from the Senate um and
that is actually unique amongst the
other authorities to have that tie in
how many full-time
employees so we have five full-time
employees and then another four
full-time equivalent
contractors that's very different than
the Housing Authority 130 or something
they yes our models are very different
um we we have a very different focus in
just the way we do things I mean I'm not
saying it's better or worse but um very
very different um so uh the mission of
the BFA really is to help growing
companies in the state and nonprofit
organizations Access Capital
specifically loan Capital there are all
kinds of reasons why a small business or
a big business might have trouble
getting a loan from their Bank um you
know these are good companies who check
99 out of 100 of the boxes that a bank
needs them to check um but they don't
check box number 100 and what we have
seen over the last 30 or 40 years since
the BFA has been around um the list of
boxes you need to check with banks and
increasing sort of not blaming the feds
but Federal Regulations makes it's just
there's more boxes to check and more
folks that fall through the cracks so
the state legislature in the early '90s
created the BFA with a couple different
tools to help these good companies turn
uh ah gez we at the bank really wish we
could help you we actually think we
should help you to yes we can help you
and we run a number of programs for
businesses that need as little as $5,000
$15,000 a few hundred, that's actually
our busiest program to some of the
state's key Economic Development
projects you know we were the ones that
did the Bae expansion in Manchester
three of Sig Sour's most recent
expansions the New Balance development
in London Derry and then with any luck
tomorrow or Friday closing on the big
new Wayland engineering facility in
Charlestown so and everything in between
so um I'll take you through a little bit
of the programs I won't um well I'll do
as much as as as you want um but the
bfa's most active program and actually
the least well-known program is called
CAP which stands for Capital Access
program in our statute it's actually the
cap program so it's actually Capital
Access program program which I got get
no no end of tickle out of but um this
is a very interesting program 90% of the
bfa's activities of of loans that are
made um are through this program and I
think you'll see is a theme here so
these are all bank loans these are
private sector loans to private entities
these are not bfa's money that's being
lent out so or the states so the the way
cap works is every Bank in the state
participates and some of the credit
unions when they have a loan they want
to make to a borrower that's 500,000 or
less the average is about 75,000 that's
pretty good um they think the loan's
fine but they need some help they can
Cho they can choose to enroll it in cap
and when they do small percentage of
that loan paid for by the borrower goes
into a bank account at that bank the BFA
matches that contribution somewhat to
that same account and so you get this
little pool of money for every loan that
that bank makes and it's the bank's
account but that pool grows and grows a
little bit at a time for each cap loan
the bank
enrolls if any of that bank's cap loans
default and they can't fully recover
from Liquidation of the assets of the
borrower um the bank can cover its
losses up to the degree that they've
establish these reserves in these cap
accounts so it's like this Self
insurance program for business loans
that the BFA helps administer and it's
anywhere from a low-end 50 up to
150 businesses and nonprofits a year
almost 6,000 um companies in the state
use the cap program it's a very active
program
um the cost of it uh is essentially what
was negotiated in '92 when we were
formed is the BFA is allowed to use the
interest income on these cap accounts as
the source of the match for contributing
to those accounts and so it's this
little self-perpetuating engine um and
it's it's very neat actually if you had
told me it worked uh before I knew about
it I wouldn't have believed you but it
does um and you can see in uh one of the
Pages this is just like our annual
glossy report type thing this is just
these are the small businesses that got
a cap loan last year so um it's an
efficient program uh it runs virtually
with one person it's all eign and you
know technology enabled so it's 24 hours
for the borrowers there's not a lot of
heavy lifting it's it's very efficient
the reason that the BFA has helped
hundreds of millions billions of dollars
of private Capital get to these
companies is we partner with the private
sector right so the banks are doing the
loan servicing right the banks are doing
the payment allocations so we can scale
up and scale down without having to add
full-time staff um you know to kind of
not spoil the later question the BFA has
not added a staff person in the last
five years um it's been very level our
kind of core operating expenses are
between 100 1 million and 1.1 million
for like all the things not including
like interest in interest out you know
like Opex and that's been you know I
actually checked because I know you
asking since 2019 2019 it was between 1
million and the next year 1.1 this year
was 1.1 so very flat
um those F do those funds come from this
interest account you're talking about or
good question no Mr chairman so the
interest just covers like the cap
contributions that the
bfa's ability to pay for its own
operations comes from the fees and
interest we charge to Banks who use our
programs so for example one of the
things this is what people know us best
for although it's one of our least
common things is uh the bfa's loan
guarantee program so this is different
than cap these are for loans of a
million to say 10 million medium-sized
businesses or you know depends on where
you are know but say 20 to 100 employees
who are growing and the BFA on an
individual Case by casee basis can
guarantee those loans with the full
faith and credit of the state to get the
bank from a 90% yes to 100% yes there's
a bunch of collateral requirements you
know the loss rat's less than 1% States
never had to pay in 30 plus years on one
of these guarantees um but when we do a
a loan guarantee we charge the bank 1%
of the guaranteed balance on an annual
basis which is actually passed to the
the
borrower um so it makes the loan more
expensive um we actually think that's
kind of a good thing because it's a
disincentive to use the program if it's
not needed in the eyes of the market um
and it incentivizes them to pay us off
and pay the loan off and get into a
lower cost debt as soon as they can um
so there's a one % uh fee so that's like
part of our
Revenue we're also the state's issuer
for tax exempt bonds conduit bonds and
what that that is is when the when when
a town or a state borrows money it's a
municipal Bond right it's a tax exempt
lower cost rate a bond there are t many
times where a a town let's say they want
to build a new wastewater treatment
plant but they recognize that the
private sector can do it faster and
cheaper and like towns aren't
contractors right they're not going out
there and building it themselves so you
have a waste management or someone
whoever build your your plant wastewater
treatment plant so this is a public
project
right public or private entities who are
building public infrastructure projects
are allowed to borrow at that same lower
interest rate for that project if a
state agency like us goes in verifies
its up true public purpose project
there's a bunch of tax compliance it's
you know kind of a long process uh that
we actually like doing it's quite
interesting to us not to I think anybody
else but um when we do that um that's
called a conduit Bond and we're
technically the issuer of that it's not
an obligation of the state one of the
reasons we're separate from the state um
and we charge a very small kind of
on10th to even half that amount of a
percent on that amount on an annual
basis and it that covers another few
hundred thousand of our fees so you add
all those up we cover ourselves um very
stable um you know th those are our big
programs there are a few others that are
quite
small um many years ago when there was
something called Reggie um the state had
a few million dollars of Reggie funds to
create a business efficiency Energy
Efficiency Loan program and so we
administer that um that's been going
ever since um you know and that's that
that's the BFA in a nutshell um but I'm
happy it's take questions so how how do
you compare with the
SBA that's a great question uh Mr
chairman so I would say we are diff
different the SBA is huge um the SBA is
a valuable partner to folks um they are
you know much more uh regimented right
they kind of have very thick policies
and procedures and we have some they're
just thinner um you know we're a little
bit more like okay we can actually go
visit the business and see if this is
really a good idea or not where they're
more of a like do you qualify XYZ so a
little more nimble not trying to insult
them or anything but a little more
Nimble it's a state level small group
versus a big Federal program okay all
right representative Campell thank you
Mr chair I I had some I'm looking at
this paper I'm look had some questions
regarding the student loan forgiven us
program uh I'm looking at it it looks
36,7 in uh forgiveness because you only
did 20 students for that amount
I'm just wondering um what was the
criteria for that how were they selected
was it for presumably New Hampshire
citizens only that had uh needed the
forgiveness and was it were the
institutions that were paid New
Hampshire universities or did did you
indeed pay out of state uh institutions
with this money uh I'm just curious
about it because sure this is something
that may be brought brought up again in
the future and I want to know how well
we spent our money here yeah thank you
representative so the BFA administers
that program um we just you know so we
don't choose kind of who gets it or how
much that was all set by the legislature
when they uh approv the the legislation
for the program and and but so here's
how so the max someone can get is
$50,000 the you have to live in New
Hampshire and work in New Hampshire
right so you have to be New Hampshire
you don't have to have gone to a New
Hampshire school um the forgiveness if
they stay at an employer for five years
is actually being paid to their student
loan provider a bank or a whoever a Sofi
or Fanny right right Sally May so um so
the the eligible industry is the
regenerative medicine industry this was
sort of spearheaded by Dean Cayman and
the army
Manchester area stuff that was going on
and what happened was all the companies
that were sort of being spun out of that
had approached the legislature and said
you know we want this
program um the enroles are the employees
that the employers pick so it's the
employers using this program as a tool
to recruit who they think are the most
desirable
employees um the average is like you
said 36,000 I assume that's because the
lower debt you have like the less the
less meaningful student debt forgiveness
is to recruit you right uh I had
predicted it would be more like in the
middle 25 but you don't see a lot of
people on that 5,000 7,000 because
they're like I don't care if you forgive
my decks I don't have very much so it
wasn't like needs-based at all it was
more to trying to get Talent recruit
talent and this was an incentive yes
that's exactly right um it was this is a
this was a Workforce Development
recruitment strategy um the bfa's job
actually working with uh Granite Advance
formerly NE the New Hampshire higher
education assistance Foundation like
we're just doing identity
verification checks in and out you know
if you fit the program you fit you fit
the program okay uh we don't charge
anything for it it's Pro bonus
okay thank you yes sir I'm guessing this
is something the Senate threw in with
pension I uh I do recall it came from
the Senate if I recall correctly yeah
they added like a 100 pages to house
build too so all right so one of the
reasons I called you in was to ask about
this because this is the company I'm
very familiar with yeah this is rust to
crust right so um so you loan the money
they went bankrupt a couple years
later um so who lost
out so great question um besides my
5-year-old who loves their Pizza um I
don't think there'll be any real losses
um so we guaranteed two loans for rustic
crust um one was a small equipment loan
of um I think it was like 800,000 and
then one was to buy the the building
that they're in they were in two
buildings one rented one one purchased
and that was um I think approximately
three million for their manufacturing
facility so when so these were this was
a bank loan the BFA backs
75% of any amount the bank loses after
they've pursued all the collateral and
by law we have to have at least an 80%
or better loan to value in order for us
to award the guarantee so the assets
have to be present with a discount
buffer to fully pay the guarantee and
only if like we go below that buffer the
BFA covers a percentage of the
percentage below the buffer so um that
situation actually it was it's pretty
recent they went out of business this
year or no sorry late last year um yeah
late last year um they are still in the
process of of of liquidation right so a
bunch of the equipment has been sold the
equipment loan is almost fully paid and
there's more equipment left to liquidate
so we're very confident there um it's
public record the appraisal on the
building was $4 million the debt
outstanding is $3 million we're pretty
confident in today's market that the
bank debt will be paid if it's not um
it's going to come out of the
statutorily required reserve the BFA has
to set aside when we do a loan guarantee
and that's what will happen it's
actually
um a little bit of a sad story it's uh I
hate to say I don't want to say it's not
the business's fault because of course
it's the business's fault um but they
were actually doing fairly well and they
had some expected significant investor
Capital that got pulled last minute due
to issues with the fund of the investor
not the company's performance and they
had spent all their money on a big new
contract that they were growing and next
thing you know there it was a liquidity
issue so they couldn't order the flour
to make their pizza so then the Flower
company said well now your cash on
delivery where you had millions of
dollars of term of of vendor and it just
sort of very quickly went the wrong way
the buyer of the assets on the equipment
is actually already up and running and I
think I think the plan is to bring 9 of
those people back to work um and I think
they're already starting so when I say
no one's going to lose out I actually
think it'll be in different hands but
it'll be okay yeah I will lose that I
will because I'm I'm a was a shareholder
um but for many many years so anyway
umor yeah and and the guy who bought it
is from your board
actually yeah there was a uh a bid and
he a fund he's part of yeah I think he
did yeah okay so um other questions how
are we doing I guess
we're well it was just this was actually
the first I think it was the first in
Angel investment I made when I moved to
New Hampshire so I I moved to New
Hampshire it'll be 20 years in
July so we've had this
investment 18 years 19 something like
that yeah so you saw like that was like
the Foodies days you know that was just
after
Foodies so I I know Brad and all that
yeah okay and it was the next town over
it's in Pittsfield so that's that was
kind of interesting all right so um what
do we got next here judicial
brand and nobody's
here oh they're out in the hall okay and
thank you very much great there there
was one other questions uh Mr chairman
there was one other General fund program
I want I don't know if on here if it's
if you want me to talk so uh last year
no two years ago um the state approved a
$200,000 pery year grant for nine
Regional development corporations it was
10 now it's nine um one merged with
another and it's a capacity Grant no
strings attached to those groups it's a
10-year
authorization the state uh I'm not
actually 100% sure why but asked the BFA
if we would kind of take that money in
divide by 10 now by nine send the checks
out we do that um so I think
technically I think technically we
receive those General funds and then uh
we send them so in full disclosure Mr
you
e
good afternoon Mr
chairman you ready for us yeah okay let
me uh first uh thank uh the chair and
members of division one for your time
this afternoon I want to introduce who's
with me seated directly next to me is
Donna Raymond a familiar face to the
finance committee who's our fiscal
manager and then behind me Are the
officers of the administ ministrative
counsel of the judicial branch so this
is Ellen Christo who is the
administrative judge of the circuit
court next to her is uh judge Beth
Kissinger who's the deputy
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court uh chief justice Mark Howard of
the superior court and next to Chief
Justice Howard is Diane Martin who's the
director of the administrative office of
the courts our our objective here today
I'll just uh ask you to
turn to uh slide two is our mission
statement slide three let me just give
you a road map of what we'd like to do
today first uh cover the structure of
the judicial branch and I know there are
many returning members of division one
so this may be old news to you but just
to orient and level set everyone on who
we are and what we do second to give you
a brief overview of some of the
challenges and opportunities we see and
then third uh give you uh an overview of
our efficiency budget as submitted last
September and as part of that Mr
chairman we do have uh the responses to
your questions that you submitted uh for
the first part of our presentation if
it's okay with the division I'd like to
do a little bit of tag team so my
colleagues can get up here and talk
about their respective courts uh slide
four you see the basic structure of the
judicial branch uh we have two trial
courts the superior court and the
Circuit Court uh one appell Court in New
Hampshire the Supreme Court court and we
are all supported by the administrative
office of the court so that's the
depiction on the left side uh now I'd
like to turn it over to uh judges
Court good afternoon thank you for
having us in today appreciate it so
starting on uh Slide Five and I
apologize if it's done and if you
already know the structure but I'm just
so we can uh have a baseline so
everybody is familiar with it uh the
circuit court is the largest of the
courts uh in the state um we often refer
to it as the People's Court because this
is where 80 to 85% of citizens of New
Hampshire who access the court system
come to the Circuit
Court um we have three divisions the
district family and probate divisions uh
the Circuit Court was created in 2011 as
a result of cre of uh condensing those
three courts uh into one with just one
um so a couple of things to uh to note
about the Circuit Court uh one of it
which is that a significant majority of
the litigants who come to Circuit Court
are
self-represented uh there are some case
types where we actually have 90% of
litigants that are
self-represented uh so that is something
that is in the top of our minds as we uh
do anything in the court uh in addition
to the trial court the Circuit Court
also oversees a number of programs or
units um I'm not going to list them all
but a few of them include the uh
information center which I'll talk more
about in a moment the domestic violence
registry the office of arbitration and
mediation we do over 2,000 uh mediations
a year out of that in a number of
different case types and also the
central processing center uh which I
just want to mention briefly provides
record checks for non-confidential court
records uh we get over 21,000 requests a
year and this actually uh Revenue excuse
me generates revenue of over 5 million a
year uh that goes into the general
fund switching to um slide six just to
give you a brief overview of the
geography of the Circuit Court uh we are
split into 10 circuits they reflect the
10 uh counties in the state however
within each one of those circuits are uh
multiple courts you'll see those listed
um so for instance in Rockingham County
that's the 10th circuit uh we have six
courts brenwood Candia Dairy Hampton
Portsmouth Salem um the idea being that
they're intended to be Community cour
houses uh that reflect and are easy for
people to get to and access Justice uh
of those 34 locations there's 10 probate
divisions that reflects one in each
County uh 31 District divisions and 31
family
divisions so flipping to slide
seven uh Circuit Court judges we have 49
full-time judges uh each of those judges
does at a minimum uh district and family
divisions about a third of them also do
probate because not all the judges are
seated in a county seat uh which is
where we do
probate uh in addition to our 39
full-time judges we have a number of
part-time judges um so there's three
actual part-time or per Dums uh there's
four who are Judges who are on senior
status those are are Judges who have
retired uh but not reached the age of 70
so they sit part-time and bless you and
16 judicial referees those are uh former
judges who have reached the age of 70 um
and we appoint them as a Judicial
referee to come back and sit uh
part-time either on cases or some of
them uh do neutral case
evaluation uh a docket of that in the
Family Division for divorce and
parenting
cases um we also have two uh complex
dockets one family and one trust docket
we have two judges who were assigned
specifically to take those complex cases
uh from around the
state are any of these um judicial
positions um empty at the moment they
are not those are those are all full
thank
you uh moving to slide
eight um this gives you a sense of our
court
filings uh this past year we've got
131,132
uh that reflects new court cases also
reflects reopened cases and for those of
you who don't know a reopened case uh
might mean I'll give you an example a
divorce case that has been fully
adjudicated and is closed but some
someone comes back later to for instance
change a parenting plan or uh modify
something in the decree so that case
gets reopened um so we count that as a
as a new Case in essence because it's a
new case that's coming in that year um
so we are up uh this represents a 15%
increase over new filings from
2023 um and specifically a 21% increase
in criminal
cases uh from 2023 um which which we
believe represents primarily a return of
felonies into uh the Circuit
Court just gives you a listing here uh
it breaks out the types of filings I'm
not going to go through all of them you
can read them but it breaks out the
divisions are
there all these felony cases are those
with juries or no so there are no juries
in Circuit Court okay so the felonies
that have come back to Circuit Court
what happens is they uh all of the
criminal charges are filed initially in
Circuit Court both felonies and
misdemeanors now uh they get an
arraignment bail hearings uh and all of
the PIM in a probable cause hearing in
circuit court if the circuit court judge
finds probable cause it is bound the
case is then bound over to Superior
Court
a criminal defendant has the option to
to
um moving on to slide nine uh I just
want to briefly mention the judicial
branch information center this was
created in
2012 we have approximately 30 uh staff
people who take over 400,000 calls a
year um um again this is incredibly
important and critical for our
self-represented litigants um and I will
tell you that the
approximately uh 25 of these calls get
sent or forwarded on to the actual local
court but that means that the call
center is handling approximately 300,000
calls a year that don't have to go into
our local courts which allows our local
staff to concentrate more on either
processing cases or um serving the
thing I'm GNA turn it over to judge
Kissinger who's going to talk about the
uh new magistrate program okay so this
year we started uh as a effective
January 1 the new magistrate program
however they were hired by December 2nd
and they had four weeks of training
before um the January 2 start date um
and then they had additional few weeks
weeks of uh shadowing judges um and also
um circling back on additional training
that they determined they would need the
important thing about the magistrate
program is that we're finding is that um
they engage in certain key functions
that our Circuit Court judges undertake
um and that frees those judicial
resources to go to other case types um
and to help um in particular freeze
judicial uh resources for case types
that aren't statut mandated that may get
um delayed because we are doing the the
cases that need to be T undertaken
immediately um um as I said on January
1st they began the weekend um or holiday
coverage um and they um will do bail
determinations for a number of different
um serious crimes that is enumerated in
the statute there's there's a number of
them I I won't go through the list but I
can certainly if you if you want me to
um they also um do weekday
arraignments and they do uh bail reviews
they do probable cause hearings and they
uh can review warrants both arrest and
search warrants um they've I personally
um am in charge of when a judge calls in
sick to find coverage and I can tell you
we've already tapped our referees um so
I thank the legislature for that um and
um they provide Statewide coverage for
when we need to have a next day
arraignment or warrant taken care of um
and what this allows is when if there's
professional development um the those
arraignments those warrants get covered
while the judges are undergoing the
professional development which frankly
is is quite important we we're doing a
lot of refresh trainings because we
cover such a broad spectrum of cases
across three divisions um we also
importantly during the weekday they do
bail determinations uh for local police
departments so the local police
department can bring the arreste to the
local court and have a bail
determination with a magistrate either
in person or over video and that creates
efficiencies for the courts because then
if we don't need to use staff members
who are bail Commissioners and they can
service the other members of our
community um this is particularly in our
rural um courts because um often times
it's hard to find a bell commissioner in
a in a more rural area um so that's
that's quite important so um again go
are these positions appointed by the
governor or
no no
no so the uh positions are appointed by
the Chief Justice that's uh the way the
legislation uh reads um and we uh judge
Howard just Howard uh was in charge of a
search committee and uh we did all of
the interviewing uh sent finalist
candidates for interviewing an
appointment by the Chief Justice and
they're not part of the judge's
retirement system and stuff like that is
that's that's correct they are similar
to um a a referee uh not a Judicial
referee but uh a referee in our system
so they're an employee yes
classification thank you uh other
questions yes thank you Mr chair um I
believe in the bill we authorized it was
more than three didn't we authorize 10
or five was a how you doing on getting
the so I'm gonna I'm gonna let the chief
handle that one okay believe the bail
Reform Bill uh authorized three
initially and permitted me to go back to
fiscal and ask for two additional okay
and uh are you going to follow up on
that uh we're we're we just launched
this so we're going to assess the
workload and
and uh make a determination down the
road okay thank you thank you at this
point um we're going to turn it over to
court right uh good afternoon just as a
reminder I'm Mark Howard I'm the chief
judge of the Superior Court uh the
Superior Court as I'm sure you know is a
constitutional court it's established in
part two article
72a um we are the court of general trial
court jurisdiction uh here in New
Hampshire and what that means is um we
uh conduct all jury trials in felony uh
cases some misdemeanor cases all civil
cases uh to a certain
um uh monetary
threshold um there is the right to a
jury trial in civil cases in our state
under our constitution where the minimum
is $1,500 so you can well imagine that
that increases our uh
dock it quite a bit um is that a a
constitutional it is $1,500 yeah around
a long time I see okay all right so
maybe we can work on
that um we also have uh what was created
in 2023 the land use docket U we were
given an additional judge committed to
that effort and we have the business and
Commercial dispute docket uh the land
use docket sits in Manchester as does
the uh the business and Commercial
dispute uh we also house uh many of our
treatment courts all of the drug courts
in New Hampshire are in Superior Court
uh we are developing mental health
courts in Superior Court they also exist
uh primarily in Circuit Court uh and uh
the legislature authorized the creation
of the veterans court um beginning this
year in the middle of this year my
understanding is that's not funded yet
but it's been created to have a veterans
court in each of our counties throughout
the state uh we also started a pilot
program of what we refer to as a young
adult uh treatment court and I'm going
to get into this more uh later in the
presentation that's in Manchester and
the focus essentially is on um
defendants who are between the ages of
18 and 25 they're usually come from uh
Gang Related associations and we try to
get them out of the gangs and provide
them uh treatment and uh counseling
through uh the court
supervision the superior court is a
County based court so we have 11 sites
um Hillsboro has two sites Manchester
and nashwa and then every other county
has one site in the county
seat our census is uh 23 full-time
judges that's 22 who actively sit plus
the chief um and we are at full
compliment right now um we are expecting
although it's not mandatory we're
expecting a retirement later this
year we have two senior active status
judges what that means is a judge who
has retired but is not yet aged 70 uh so
they still have full Authority as a
judge and but they are limited in the
amount of time that they can sit it's
basically 25% of a full-time
judge and then we have four judicial
referees that is fully retired judges
over the age of 70 they no longer have
constitutional authorities but they
still handle some matters for us
particularly in the area of settlements
and uh arbitrations and mediation in in
Superior
Court Supreme Court the one Appel Court
in our state five justices one Chief and
four associate
justices uh in addition to our pellet
responsibilities uh we have
responsibility generally with respect to
the oversight of legal profession in New
Hampshire including attorney admission
attorney dis IPL liaison with the New
Hampshire Bar Association which U
so-called unified bar and the
development of court rules under our
constitution is the Chief Justice and
consultation with the associate Justice
who have ultimate responsibility for the
judicial branch on slide 17 you will see
our uh case load this is for calendar
24 um and the the real measure of our
productivity is that uh bottom um number
752 of the cases that flowed through our
court were finally resolved that I will
note for the record is the highest
number since 2015 so a very productive
year last year uh with that I'll ask
director Marner come up Mr chief justice
yes can you explain the difference
between cases accepted and full court
arguments heard so you can take a case
but not actually hear it sort of is that
yes that we we have a volume of cases
about 750 a year we elect to have oral
argument and opinions published where a
case is going to affect the development
of the law in other words where statute
which hasn't been interpreted before
needs interpretation by us or the common
law will be will be Advanced the other
cases are disposed of by by court order
and and some cases are not we we have a
large mandatory jurisdiction but some is
discretionary and some cases are
disposed of by not accepting them so you
make your decision by reading what
happened in the case is that all all of
the cases have five sets of eyes on them
and um they're resolved either by
opinion or by order gotcha thank you
yeah good
afternoon so the admin Administrative
Office of the courts is is a fairly
typical administrative support system
for the courts um we provide all the
typical things that you would expect it
um HR accounting fiscal Donna leads our
fiscal Department um general counsel
Aron krian is here um she does our
government Affairs so you may have met
her before um we also have operations
and we have internal audit so we do
audits on our on our internal um
operations
um Communications a is here so he's in
the AOC um treatment Court coordination
the Supreme Court transferred to the AOC
in the in this bium actually and so we
just do the administrative support for
that um access and Community
engagement uh justice data and
statistics Information Technology that's
probably our biggest uh spending piece
other than court security and and we
have procurement and purchasing
facilities and buildings and grounds one
thing that you may not know that we do
is Provide support for some of the other
offices that are part of the court so
YDC claims which the legislator
legislature created is actually in
supported by the AOC the attorney
discipline office the officer of bar
Admissions and the judicial conduct
committee so there are a lot of
different um functions that we support I
just wanted to call out a few noteworthy
things that are that are different and
everyone does a great job but in the
recent past we stood up a grants unit
and that unit has been able to since
2022 and it started um get $26 million
in Grants and and you'll see later that
that money is what's supporting most of
the new initiatives we're doing in the
branch it's not General funds um and the
office of access and Community
engagement which the Supreme Court
started about a little over a year ago
they're doing a lot of projects to
support proa litigants coming into the
courts and so those are funded with
grants as well and last we started a
procurement and Purchasing Office which
has done some really great work at
reducing costs and trying to look for
efficiencies couple examples toners that
we used to pay uh $100 for we just got
uh for 16 and envelopes regular order
consistently paid the same amount $200
off so they're doing a really good job
trying to earn their salaries
so do you not have access to Department
of administrative Services purchasing we
do so we can share in the benefits of
their contracts if they are things that
we use and in some cases there are other
things that we use um we have different
Services we use different things so
anytime we can if their prices are
better but we like to try to beat them
all right thank
you representative w
thank you uh when was the last time we
updated the filing fees so I'm actually
working on Melissa asked me for that
information and I gathered it yesterday
from the chief's um clerk at the Supreme
Court because they're all set by Supreme
Court so it they have varied and changed
over time but I'm going to get you a
welcome so beginning on slide 20 uh just
very
briefly um share with the committee some
of what we think are challenges and
opportunities slide 21 is a
list
um so let me start with challenges and
the first one on slide 22 is Safety and
Security
um there is one issue that keeps me up
at night and that is the Safety and
Security of the thousands of people who
walk through our 40 plus doors every day
and our Safety and Security is provided
in sort of a bifurcated way our County
Sheriffs provide safety security in our
uh Superior cour houses and AOC
employees court security officers
provide security in our circuit courts
with the support of the legislature
we've made some really significant
progress on this front our court
security officers are now able to be
trained by a special curriculum
developed at the police standards and
training Council because of legislation
enacted by uh the legislature we've also
uh benefited from arpa funds one-time
spending but we are doing one-time
assessments of each one of our physical
locations to uh to be able to catalog
deficiencies that we might be able to
come back to the legislature and
identify um next I'm going to ask Chief
Justice to to talk about the YDC
challenge we face on slide
23 so just by way of a little bit of
background as you know the Youth
Development Center has been the subject
of a lot of litigation and the claims
process that was created by the
legislature a few years ago um those
cases
um although about 800 of them have gone
to the claims process there's an
additional
1350 plus or minus in the Superior
Courts that are in full litigation in
the Superior Courts
those cases have um created a extremely
significant resource crisis for the
Superior Court both in terms of
Administration staff in the clerk's
offices that have to administer we have
an electronic filing system the manager
of the electronic filing system center
um literally Works night and day just
keeping up with the YDC
cases um that's in addition to our other
22,000 cases that we have filed every
year in thisi
fors um these uh cases will are going to
be around for years and just so you're
are clear about it the the claims
process is only for cases where the
state is the defendant uh the state is
being sued there are about 520 cases
where although the state is a defendant
the other defendants and the primary
defendants in those cases is private
contractors who contracted with the
state to run youth homes um uh
throughout the state during those years
um so even if all of the cases and so
far almost none of them have left the
superior court and gone to the claims
process only about a hundred in the last
quarter have actually gone to the claims
process even if all of them go to the
claims process the Superior Court will
still have to deal with about 520 of
these extremely complex cases I'm sure
many of you saw the news on the mean
case uh last year about just how complex
those cases are nearly all of them are
like
that thank you chief justice Howard
slide 24 refers to a chall oh I'm sorry
so oh yes last time when we dealt with
allocating the money to pay the
settlements um the Attorney General said
to us it's up to us how much we let
somebody sue us you know what I mean we
could pass a law saying everybody gets
$10,000
or something is that is that accurate or
is that you know so one of the great
Parts about being a judge is I can't
give legal advice
so um I'm going to have to defer to the
Attorney General on the state's ability
to both um impose sovereign immunity
that is you can't suici at all or the
limits and what the Constitutional
limits are of uh how much you can cap a
recovery that issue is actually in
litigation in that mean case right now I
you slide 24 refers to the third
challenge we've identified broadly
called access to Justice and I want to
make clear this is
not solely a New Hampshire problem it is
truly a national problem and as you
heard from Judge Christo up to 90% in
particular case types in our Circuit
Court have a self represented litigant
that is a litigant without an attorney
on one one or both sides of the
V uh on and that's the Civil side on the
criminal side where our constitutions
both
require uh that c the criminally accused
have an attorney be appointed we're
facing another kind of Crisis which is
the public defender office is simply not
able to provide enough attorney repres
representation for all the criminal
defendants out there the LBA I commend
uh an LBA audit of the judicial Council
judicial Council it's not part of the
judicial branch it's part of the
executive branch they did an audit last
October it's well worth reading and
you'll see in there that in March of
2023 uh between 20 and
uh
incarcerated defendants incarcerated
their Liberty withheld uh were awaiting
appointment of attorney before they
could come to our courts this has an
effect on our courts I think our trial
judges would say uh without uh attorney
representation it it slows the
processing of the
case um back to the Civil side I do want
to commend the legislature for stepping
up uh to help us address this issue last
year uh the the legislature passed a
very important bill
which allows paralal
representation in circuit courts in
certain ta case types Statewide this was
an important initiative of uh then
representative Gordon and uh we're we're
uh very hopeful about the ability to
provide at least some representation in
our circuit courts by paral leals so I I
want to commend the legislature for that
and uh I also uh want to note that we
are using one-time arpa funds to assist
our efforts uh to
identify means to assist
self-representative litigant in our
courts representative cell and then
representative MTS thank you Mr chair um
so without legal representation what's
the percentage of or chances of the
people winning their
case uh our trial judges do they're very
very very best to to be fair and
impartial with notwithstanding whether a
person is represented or not represented
so that's a I think an impossible
question to answer with respect do
is as an attorney as someone who's been
in court as someone who's been in court
against um a self-re represented
litigant is it difficult for a self
representative litigant to walk into
court a completely foreign atmosphere
where they speak a different
language and achieve the same level of
Justice I would say not okay and our
entire profession is letting down the
people of not just New Hampshire but the
entire country as I said this is a
national problem and we need to do
better about on it okay thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chief justice for taking my question is
is there a constitutional limit on how
long someone can be held without having
a
council um so there's no Hardon task
limit but at some point without councel
the the defendant is so deeply
prejudiced that it's likely that the
dismissed okay turning now to uh
opportunities and one of the one of the
crown jewels of our judicial branch has
been
uh our adult drug court and I know many
members have been deeply involved in the
expansion of the adult adult drug court
over the years uh that same concept has
been expanded if you will to other areas
and um chief justice Harry you want to
so I'll talk a little bit about um some
of those areas my primary focus is on
drug court I sat as a drug court judge
for a little over eight years I don't
sit as often anymore be but I do back up
other judges when they're not available
um I I want to talk to you about uh the
success of that program and the um as a
side maybe it could be primary for some
but as a side the financial benefit that
it produces for the state the cost in
Savings in not incarcerating folks and
putting them through this program uh
when they are successful is astronomical
it it costs 10 plus times more to
incarcerate somebody than it does to
have them in a program like this what we
look for are folks who are both
high-risk that is a risk to recidivate
or to commit another crime and they are
high need they are severely addicted uh
to fentanyl meth or other opiates or
stimulants um and are in need of
treatment then they come into a very
intense supervision and treatment
program um we just had our
1,000th graduate uh this year and um
that represents a 50% little over 50%
graduation rate since the start of uh
drug courts uh close to 20 years ago in
straford County the the legislature
created Statewide drug courts in 2016 so
that effort is about nine years old now
um a 50% graduation rate is phenomenal
uh they've been through uh every phase
of treatment every phase of Court
supervision um and so many of them uh
are leading healthy productive um safe
uh lives and sober uh so I can't say
enough about the importance of this
program uh to the citizenry um and the
court is extremely proud to be a part of
it uh mental health courts uh do exist
primarily in the circuit courts we've
started to um house them in we've
started one in belnap county and we're
going to start
expanding um this is similar to drug
court there may be some um addiction
issue but primarily it's a mental health
issue that we are attempting to manage
and then change behaviors veterans court
as I mentioned earlier was created by
the legislature to start this year um we
do have two veterans courts in Superior
Court and I think there are two in
circuit um they are essentially informal
dockets uh judge St hair manages uh some
veterans in Rockingham County and also
in marac County with the the assistance
of case management through the Veterans
Administration and we're trying to
expand that Statewide uh and I did
mention the young adult um Court pilot
program um the other expertise is with
circuit on these other
courts I'll stand up I'm more
comfortable as a lawyer actually um let
me ask a little about drug court if I
might yeah
um so what Char does the per is the
person who's there always pleading
guilty or what's their and they always
charge with possession only or what's
going on yes and no okay um we are a
post plea Post sentenc in court uh so
they do plead guilty to an offense it's
not always a drug offense in fact more
often than not it is not a drug offense
it's some other offense almost entirely
driven by their addiction whether it be
theft burglaries um we are taking higher
risk um defendants now um and
so um the answer is yes you have to
plead in and you are sentence but that
sentence is suspended and you are placed
on probation for a period of three years
which is um the period that will likely
take to get you through drug court we
hope you're done in 18 months but it's
usually a little longer than that um
does that answer both of your questions
yeah I had a follow oh and the other one
is if you successfully complete you can
petition the court to a null your
conviction gotcha y when I read the the
drug court um law it seemed to me that
there's an awful lot of people in the
room paid by who are state employees
right there's there's there's a the
sheriff there's the uh the doctor
there's the corrections person there's
the that's that and the other thing
attorney all kinds of other people plus
the guy right plus the defendant
do you think some of that is overkill I
mean you know because it just seemed
like a lot of right so I I understand um
your point and first I want to um make
the point that not everybody in the drug
court team is a state employee in fact
in most of our drug courts they're not
we have memorandums of understanding
with agencies in Manchester for example
the entire program except for the judge
probation the prosecutor and the defense
attorney all work for the la8 hospital
they're on a contract with us similar to
Cheshire county straford county is a
little bit different there's a a healthy
mix of County Employees state employees
and private contractors who provide the
treatment so it's really a mixed vag on
the question of Overkill um one of the
things that we are mandated by Statute
to do is follow best practices that are
set by what used to be known as the
National Association of drug court
professionals now it's referred to as
allrise and the the best practice is to
have the judge defense attorney
prosecutor probation officer law
enforcement representative a case
manager and treatment all at the table
and if you're fortunate enough to have a
housing program they should be at the
table too because that's a real key to
success thank you representative Bron
thank you um thank you very much um we
heard a bill the other day last week
that would provide a um appropriation to
WellPoint um um to support their young
adult homeless shelter and I was
wondering if in the young adult Court
Pilot if you've been engaging it all
with a wellp point um I I have not I
don't sit in that court that judge
Delker who's the supervisory judge um in
Manchester runs that court that is a
question I'll have to provide an answer
in writing to you after the hearing and
get um a better sense from him of the
interaction with wello okay thank you
very much
all right I'm going to talk briefly
about the family treatment courts in
Circuit Court um these courts we started
a pilot program in Sullivan County in
2021 um and the goal is to increase
access of uh parent who is in the abuse
and neglect uh who's part of abuse and
neglect matter um where one parent has a
substance use disorder and the approach
is uh seen as a best practice where you
have a wraparound team approach with um
multi-stakeholders including the courts
including the courta appointed special
Advocates Casa DCF parent attorneys
treatment providers and then some other
community providers and the idea is to
engage the parent UPF front with their
substance use disorder and the reason is
is that it gives them a better chance of
reunifying with their child if it's
appropriate because often times these
parents are required within a year of an
adjudicated neglect or abuse to um to
correct the conditions that led to the
removal of their child with a substance
use disorder that's that's a hefty lift
and so um what it does is it brings the
whole team together with the judge and
wraps the services around this
individual to give them a better chance
of um reaching reunification which is
the goal of our um 169c cases um and it
decreases generally the time when a
child uh is out of the home and
decreases the barriers in and time to
reunification we expanded in 2024 um in
our Manchester Court it's called a
supported family approach it's a
different category of parents usually
with children between birth and three
years old um and where the parents are
at risk of or are separated from their
children where there is one parent um
very uh for the record the family
treatment court is largely Grant funded
uh very briefly mental health uh it is
no not news to members of this committee
that mental health and
curring disorder of substance use is a
huge profound public health problem
and it affects our Judicial System uh
people cycling through our system
repeatedly on slide uh
27 you will see something called the
sequential intercept model this is a
model that's been used around the
country it divides the criminal justice
system into five intercepts what we are
doing at no cost to the taxpayer
convening uh workshops in each one of
our counties bringing together
stakeholders to identify opportunities
where people who might otherwise be
Justice involved are diverted uh out of
our system and the object there is to uh
increase Public
Safety uh save public dollars and most
importantly get people the treatment
they
need um I'm mindful of the time Mr
chairman
uh I mean we're okay if you are so okay
yeah we everyone good can we continue
okay uh I'll invite judge kisto up on uh
Innovation is really really important in
the judicial branch and we've just
highlighted a few um areas oh I'm sorry
judge Kissinger she going to talk about
our landlord tenant uh diversion program
so I'll try to keep it quick again um it
this is Grant funded um and it began um
in November of 2021 and it is a two-step
process in our landlord tenant cases um
the first is a pre-file ing diversion to
mediation if you get an eviction notice
um there is uh instructions to um in
that notice on how to access um the
mediation it is efficient because um for
everyone because you there's never a
landlord tenant case
filed um and it's also
dignified um as the landlord and the
Tenant works out um a resolution there's
also post filing in three courts
Manchester National and conquered um I
presided over one of the first sessions
um in with that post uh filing mediation
and again um the parties come in
oftentimes there are multiple cases and
um again it's very efficient because the
parties can choose to sit down with the
landlord and the Tenant and they have a
mediator and they work out um how to um
resolve the case it saves time and money
for the landlord and also um gives uh a
voice to the tenant and again it's also
a more dignified way for people to
resolve these very emotionally charged
cases um and um so we have uh through
May 31 uh it affected
1,945 households um there were 70% with
agreements um and 41% of the agreements
uh allowed the tenant to stay and this
in includes um even those without uh
Federal funding for you during the at
the end of the pandemic for rent um so
uh it's a very Innovative and I and
nationally recognized actually by the
bar assoc American Bar Association um
for being effective thank
you so in the superior report we have
one significant Innovation occurring and
that is what we refer to as case s
company as Thompson Reuters makes this
program this is a digital evidence
platform it's a presentation program uh
so what we've done is in all of our
Superior Courts now in cases that do not
involve a jury yet we're working on that
um all the evidence that you want to
submit documentary photograph and so
forth uh is done over this digital
evidence platform and it's presented to
the judge through the witness and the
attorneys all digitally uh that mean
that makes for a much more efficient
management of that record um case Center
is our official record um pleased to say
that we had one of our first appeals in
the Supreme Court where the certified
record went with the push of a button
instead of printing out hundreds of
pages of documents and having somebody
drive it to the Supreme Court um so we
are seeing some real benefits there in
terms of Manpower we are moving this um
platform and program to jury trials we
had our first one in Rockingham County
this past fall uh starting to do a few
more and and eventually our hope is
throughout the state we'll be fully on
2025 moving to uh slide 31 I'd like to
talk about and highlight a uh a joint
pilot program with the trial courts both
circuit and Superior uh doing text
message reminders similar to what you
might get uh when you're you know for a
doctor or dentist appointment on your
cell phone uh it we started this program
a little while ago uh in we tested it
out in Family Mediation cases uh and
increased our uh failure to appear or
decreased excuse me our failure to
appear rate by 40% which is huge and the
reason it we're working on trying to
decrease failure to appear rates is that
um it takes up so much Court time when a
defendant in particular fa fails to
appear uh for judge time staff time uh
prosecutor time uh defense attorney time
so it and everything has to get
rescheduled sometimes electronic bench
warrants go out now we have bail
hearings when they're picked up so to
eliminate uh failure to appears or
significantly reduce them uh We've
started this pilot in straford Superior
and uh Rochester Criminal Division we
don't have numbers yet because it's so
new it just started in November uh but
anecdotally we have great feedback um on
November 5th every defendant uh that
appeared in court said that they had
received uh the text reminder and one of
them said it was the only reason that
they were at court that day uh we've
been getting great feedback from some of
the um def attorneys for defendants as
well saying that it helped their client
get to court and some of them it was the
only reason that they managed to get to
court so assuming this is successful
we're plan to roll it out uh Statewide
in the criminal divisions and then uh in
a perfect world we'll roll it out
further in areas like small claims where
we have huge failure to appear rate in
those
cases so Mr chairman we'll move to the
third part of our presentation which is
our efficiency request page 33 um slide
33 uh reminder to uh committee members
the judicial branch is a little bit
different the way its budget is
submitted uh the uh Governor uh can make
comments with our budget but as um it's
it's essentially a pass through um 34
basic facts which kind of uh Define the
playing field for our budget one
Personnel overwhelmingly 75% our cost CA
cost are fixed both in terms of salaries
and
benefits uh and health and dental as I'm
sure the division has heard has gone up
significantly uh we have limited control
over non-personnel costs uh as mentioned
our County Sheriff's great Partners in
in security uh they are reimbursed by
the judicial branch uh we also make
certain transfers to das who actually
run our Courthouse manage our our
physical
locations uh and then we do rent cour
houses from third parties and it we are
92% generally
funded um Governor senuna requested of
executive branch agencies that they
submitted an efficiency budget as the
division well knows uh that was 4% below
uh fiscal 25 uh adjusted authorized we
met that Target in what we submitted to
the governor there are some consequences
and uh I just want to run through them
uh circuit cour houses in Candia and
Claremont will have to be closed um jury
trials will be restricted in two months
in Superior Court July and
December uh we are reducing the number
of funded non-judge positions by
31.4 uh we have uh we will be ciling uh
Appropriations for our pum Courthouse
security much of our circuit court
security is overwhelmingly provided by
per DM officers they are paid on
obviously a daily
basis um we will reduce the payments to
our County Sheriffs we're going to defer
the implementation the veterans court
we've made no request to fund that and
uh we are curtailing reimbursements uh
to our providers in the in the uh adult
drug
court the next slide you will see what
we've identified as prioritized needs
and I think they'll reflect the
presentation to to to the moment uh
excuse me Mr
chairman no no problem representa Le
thank you so it must have been more than
15 years ago Senator Odell and I toured
the state there was a request to close a
number of district courts they were
called at the time and Claremont was one
of those courts that we said should stay
open so I'm curious why Claremont was
picked because the outcry of closing
Claremont was quite loud at the time I
would assume when Claremont hears that
the now circuit court is being suggested
to be closed that there'll be some push
back I think they'll be push back on any
Court closure I mean they are as as um
judge Christo stated they've evolved in
sort of a community location in the in
the communities that do po uh circuit
courts Claremont was chosen I'll let um
judge Christo amp uh supplement this but
basically it is relatively Co close to
Newport and it can be the location in
Claremont can be relatively easily
accommodated within our footprint in
Newport and the second is that the the
um physical space in Claremont is
extremely challenging it's just um it
it's it's not ideal for a courthouse
just put it that way uh further question
Mr chairman thank now is that rented
space or is that owned by this it's yeah
it's rented from the City of Claremont
yes okay thank you thanks Mr chairman
represent thank you Mr chairman um given
the concern you expressed about um court
security um it it's a little surprising
to me that um there would be these these
Cuts in um in C Cod uh court security
included in your uh in your
ideal prioritize needs um additional
resources uh to address the issues that
uh chief justice Howard
identified um as he said there's
literally someone who Works in
electronic filing Center in Manchester
who comes in at 5: in the morning to
process these cases it's an employee
they're complex and we we ideally would
need do need additional resources to
process the YDC cases next prioritized
needs address what you just raised
representative months uh including oh
I'm sorry no no that's fine I actually
this the the on the YDC um amount I was
going to ask you if you have estimates
on how much you're actually expending at
this point in processing the YDC claims
well it's all been absorbed by existing
staff so this
represents our estimate of what it would
need
minimally to process the cases on a
reasonable basis without
dislocating what we've had to do
existing resources again we do just
chief justice Howard will tell you we's
got an employee who comes in early in
the morning to process these cases so
this would ask for an additional uh two
I believe it's two um Court operation
Specialists and one core monitor uh to
help process the case that's that's what
reflects as long as we're stopped I'll
ask a question yes uh security per DM
um could you hire full-time security and
um uh PDM gives
us um there costs and benefits to a PDM
system um but not having a full-time
employee is generally less expensive
than having a full-time employee our
prospective employee pool are generally
not always retired law enforcement and
so it's uh it's a better fit for that
Community um they don't want to be
full-time yes because they lose their
pension okay thank you represent sorry I
I so just going back a where it says
curtailing reimbursement payments to
County Sheriffs do you mean you're going
to pay them less and they're what is the
curtailing actually mean you'll have
less security or trying to understand
what that we've been in a discussion
with the sheriffs about how how we
reduce the reimbursement that goes with
to them and what that will mean
operationally but we we do need to
reduce the reimbursements and it does
more or less mirror our reduction in our
court security officer
prum reduction on the circuit court side
so sort of a negotiation at this point
okay I sort of had thought that might be
chairman oh thank you um I guess I would
share the same concerns that
representative Ms just mentioned as far
as the security issue and I'd be curious
um adding to that if you could provide
the dollar amount that you're proposing
to by curtailing the Appropriations per
DM if that was restored and also the uh
curtailing of reimbursement for the
counties because I can see that also
becoming a county expense and just a
pass down the county sheriff's going to
have to pay it and then the County taxes
will be impacted so slide 36
representative uh Turn the Page you'll
see it
oh oh I'm sorry I didn't turn the page
okay so so whoops just so I understand
now so because I was trying to figure
out how you how you sort of mesh the
cuts or the impacts versus your
prioritized needs so the idea is that
your list of prioritized needs would
help to take care of the operational
impacts absolutely yes okay so the
operational impacts are what
are of most concern to us and the
uh just further on court security one
one additional aspect of this is we have
a court security officer in our
courtrooms while judges are presiding
and a reduction in the amount in the
number of court security officers or
their perdm availability will
necessarily reduce that functionality
courtrooms
um again uh to representative Eble uh
just back on 36 uh the Circuit Court
positions those are the positions that
we defunded some of them and um it is
definitely a priority this legislature
had a special committee on the Family
Division last year and one of its among
its recommendations were to provide
additional support to the Circuit Court
Family Division including staff
attorneys and um primarily staff
attorneys and law clerks and and that is
that is in part what's embedded in that
number on on slide
36 interpretor costs have uh continued
to increase given um our increasingly
diverse State and um it's just a need
and uh something that we need to provide
um and that is another prioritized need
I want to emphasize this is not the
entire list of prioritized needs but it
does reflect our priorities
uh
slides uh the next three slides wa wait
wait represented Wy no again I'm I'm
thinking of the filing fees and you got
100,000 cases if you went up $10 for
every filing fee that's a million dollar
so it's a possibility that if you went
up $20 you got $2 million which would
help with some of these costs and i
would support it especially if it's been
10 years since we went up in fin in fees
I think it's it's something that's got
to be considered and I know I would and
I hope you would thank you no I know
Representatives came up in ways and
means I understand came up with and and
data
um the next three slides sort of slice
and dice are efficiency um budget and a
variety of ways slide 37 breaks down by
funding source slide 3 8 uh your expense
slide now to the questions from uh the
chair uh question number one new general
fund
Appropriations over the last five years
um there was one which is House Bill 318
last year the bail Reform Bill funds
were appropriate at ated um but they
were not part of the 4% reduction they
were sort of set
aside question number two from the chair
uh any new positions established and
funded over the last five years and the
answer appears in the spreadsheet on the
pages
so I won't go through them position by
position but they're there for the
committee's
benefit um and then finally arpa funds
uh which were displays by General funds
to date it is um the answer appears on
slide 41 a case
$48,000 so with that Mr chairman that's
our presentation obviously welcome any
questions as as we went along um we'll
see any any any more questions so just
to sort of tell people um my
understanding of the way we he he
pointed out that um their budget is
special in the sense that the governor
can say can give us a note but they
won't change the number right but I also
think it's special in the sense that we
basically give them a bottom line single
digit you know single number of General
funds and how it's spent is is really up
to them we're not budgeting even though
we got this list of positions we're not
really saying okay you know lay off this
Court Clerk and this staff attorney and
this you know that kind of thing like we
do can do with other other divisions so
it's it's really um our control is
limited
to you know here's the check kind of
thing yes representative months so then
request uh we we uh the interest of
transparency the governor did ask us to
go back uh we were in communication with
the governor's office I'll defer to her
about um her view of our communication
to her
and in what's here in the 4% reduction
are the magistrates in there or not yes
they are yes they are okay so so that
house bill 318 the bail yes all that
stuff okay good all right other
questions I want to know this budget
sorry this budget does not reflect the
revised health and dental rates there's
a notation in there I have new numbers
but we did we just wanted to match what
was submitted on September 16th gotcha
okay represent quick I I know it's
really late but just because there's so
much discussion and focus on the YDC
claims when a claim comes in you said
you have somebody there processing just
really snapshot what is involved in in
in processing a claim and then and
assuming it's going to go through the
mediation process that we've
established so we are not involved as
the court system in the settlement
claims it's housed in AOC yes right but
that's not a Judicial function it's an
administrative function with the uh with
that claims process uh judge brck and
judge Nicolosi who are the administrator
and assistant administrator they've set
out the rules for that what when I'm
referring to is our electronic filing
Center when a new suit is filed a
lawsuit in Superior Court is filed
there's the initial suit that's filed
and then and the paperwork on that is um
astronomical every case that's filed has
hundreds of pages of pleadings to it the
initially to start the case and then
every filing that occurs on that case
every motion that's filed every pleading
that's filed has to run through our
electronic filing Center and then off to
our local Court um so that one employee
is managing in excess of 1300 cases each
one of which would have dozens if not
hundreds of filings the me in case alone
[Laughter]
manage we just when the legislature set
up the claims process it created a
choice you could either do the claims
process or you could pursue a lawsuit in
in one of our courts so that's the
choice that the claimants face and at
least 1300
to date have filed in Superior Court as
opposed to the it some have filed over
here they're in both places but those
who have filed over here haven't
necessarily dismissed their cases yet I
see I the other thing I will tell uh the
division is these cases are extremely
complex multiple motions there are there
really complex legal issues in each one
of these cases
and they just get more complex given the
number of third parties involved as
chief justice Howard said they're
contractors involved who who contracted
with the state to provide certain
services so that that increases the
complexity uh and and that complexity
ultimately lands on the judge and the
court staff the superior court and and
the um 438,000 per year addition you
were requesting for
processing is that your estimate of how
much has had to be absorbed by your
staff or do you think it's an under
under um I think it's fair to say that
that's what the work of our existing
staff is doing the work of maybe four
more people that we need right
representative wer then representative
Griff thank you Mr chairman thank you
Chief um when I looked at this whyd youc
it seemed like a Feeding Frenzy for
lawyers and it it the the point I made
to one of them was you know the average
citizen keeps their nose clean works
hard to prepare themselves for a career
works hard for 40 or 50 years in a
career you're lucky if you made $2
million in your whole career here's
someone that didn't obey the rules still
doesn't obey the rules and then they
come to court and they expect Millions
when they've perhaps spent a misspent
life I just don't see the Ridiculousness
I think maybe we should put a limit on
this we put a limit on 75,000 75 million
a year rather than the 500 million that
was first put forward by the Attorney
General I thought we can't break the
budget with this Ridiculousness for
people who haven't obeyed the rules and
acting like oh you're rewarded rewarded
for what a misspent life it just doesn't
make sense to me that someone who got
abused because they abused others and
abused themselves V should be rewarded
with such and that that's the way it
looks and somebody that's on the street
says well if I send a IDC I'll just say
they be abuse me I'll become a
millionaire I mean this is this is the
example we're setting so and it it
really upsets me that I think maybe we
should a limit okay thank you but that's
our business I think I know but I think
I would go to them for
advice all right all right
representative
Griffin thank you I hope this a final
question but for those people who are
both places are in the claims process
and they're in the court if they settle
in the claims process can they still go
after a contractor in the court if they
settle with a state defendant in the
claims process yes they still have
claims against contractors and that's
based on the fact that if it's against
the state only that means if there was
abuse and it was proved it happened in a
state facility by a state actor if they
were also abused in a Contracting
facility it's a it's a it's the same
case but it's a separate claim so they
can still do that it get
steeper when you say Contracting is this
foster care or is this something yeah so
I'm trying to think of a uh
um Mount Prospect is a fairly well-known
um youth facilities throughout the state
um what they do is contract with um
Health and Human Services to Prov
provide uh whether it's foster home
child shelters um any number of there
are a number of different types of
services that were provided but yes they
are um private companies that contract
with the state to provide these
child-based
Services when I I say def I say
contractors because that's what we
devise as a shorthand way of how what to
refer to these types of defendants
representative Camal thank you Mr chair
so are these private companies are you
finding that they're starting to claim
bankruptcy and getting out of the game
before they get sued um I haven't seen
that yet um most but not all of them
have insurance policies that extend back
to that period of time I was told by a
couple of the lawyers that not all of
them have policies they they are
self-insured but many of them do than
just representa evil maybe I'll have so
I guess though the message coming away
from this is that the incredible number
of claims from YDC has the effect effect
of affecting your um processing of
Justice not just for them but for many
many others throughout the state because
there's such a backlog so it's going Way
Beyond uh the folks that are filing the
YDC claims it's affecting going to be
the whole court system we're going to be
hitting critical mass soon that we're
going to have to make choices on what
cases we can go forward on and if it's
going to be 500 plus YDC cases that's
going to the last decades quite frankly
and no other case is going to get done
the as you may have seen from the case
last year um that one trial took five
Venture all right thank you all we we'll
see you um a week from today not at 9:00
amm I
believe
thank thank you Mr chairman members of